so this story is pretty crazy apparently
some lady was at the capitol with i
think with her husband and they never
actually went inside the building
when they were flying back something
happened i don't know if this was on
their way back but they're on an alaskan
airlines flight apparently weren't
wearing masks so they got into it with
one of the staff members and got booted
off and banned from the airline
apparently then someone from alaska
airlines tipped off the fbi making
claims that these people were the ones
who stormed the capital and then the i
guess or some of the people who did and
then the fbi
because this woman is of the right
or a similar age or whatever decided to
raid her home looking for nancy pelosi's
laptop it's a really weird story
and if you just look at the photos of
the woman they're claiming was involved
in stealing the laptop and this lady in
alaska you can clearly tell they're not
the same person
so what is going on how does the how is
the fbi not figured out who stole the f
who stole the laptop yet how have they
not figured out who was laying pipe
bombs around around dc that day yet
they're able to track down some of these
you know bumbling dotards who who walked
into the into the capitol building
maybe it's just low-hanging fruit maybe
the reason the fbi goes after garage
pole rope is because it's easy he ain't
gonna do anything yeah we're gonna go
show up and then we're done with work
and trying to figure out who actually
stole something maybe that's really hard
well we'll talk about this it's kind of
a weird story but we'll be chilling
today it's a chill day it's not not a
big news day
we're talking about uh dogecoin which is
skyrocketing and bitcoin crypto and uh
just the state of social media free
speech and uh you know with stories like
this and the fbi i gotta say it's it's
been a bit of a pessimistic past couple
of weeks but we'll break all this down
maybe all these people will become
dogecoin millionaires or maybe dogecoin
is proof the system is just crumbling
before our eyes because people are
getting rich off of a meme
if you put a thousand dollars in a
dogecoin in january you'd have 1 200
1021 000 right now
something is wrong with the economy if
that's the case i'll tell you that so uh
joining us today of course is bill
ottman hey you want to introduce
yourself hey everyone great to be here
i'm bill co-founder minds and uh yeah
tim and i have been been rocking along
for a few years now just uh working on
yeah you know in the world man and you
and ian of course yeah bill contacted me
2011 or something and saw some of my
crazy youtube videos was like hey help
me start a new social network you seem
like a crazy guy he had goggles on they
had were like holographic goggles yeah
let's just see like a fly it lets you
see like a fly sees it has like 40 each
each lens is like broken into 40 little
lenses so you see this fractal and when
you look at a light you know why flies
like the light because you see 40 lights
with one eye
really draws you in there are four
lights there are 40 lights
[Laughter]
yeah yeah and i'm in the corner we're
gonna have a fun conversation tonight
not as heavily news focused it'll be
great
i have an amazing announcement my
friends if you go to timcast.com become
a member click this big old members-only
button and guess what you can now sign
up with stripe it's really really easy
you go to the site it says you can pay
with stripe you just click stripe 10
bucks a month boom it pops right up
super easy to do stripe is really
amazing just way way better and then go
to the members area get access to a ton
of exclusive members only segments
become a member because in the event
that we get shut down youtube censors us
restricts us facebook already has on my
other channels you'll be able to find
our content at timcast.com and when you
become a member i'll tell you what we're
going to do with all that sweet sweet 10
per month you give us or more if you
want to give more we're going to invest
in new shows and new content we're going
to invest in events
we're planning on doing
probably weekly events at this point
we're going to start with a few monthly
events which means if you're someone who
gives at least 25 bucks a month then
you're going to get advanced notice of
when we put out tickets for events at
the cast castle you may have noticed we
started the vlog recently and so this
precipitates the events we're going to
be doing which are going to be part of
the vlog so thank you for being members
helping us grow and i'm i'm trying
really really hard we're i should say
we're trying we're working really hard
i'm getting to the point where the shows
aren't have nothing to do with me right
so obviously i've got my my two other
channels we got this show we got the
cass castle now we're working towards
slowly getting to totally independent
shows new podcasts with with new hosts
and everything like that and that's why
we need your support we want to build
culture that's the optimism right here
that you know what we're doing is
working so we can be a bit pessimistic
when it comes to these crazy stories
about the economy the dollar inflation
the fbi black lives matter riots but uh
hey we're doing something here and uh
you guys who are members are doing are
are helping out but don't forget to like
share subscribe hit the notification
bell uh share the show if you're if
share the show with your friends if you
would like it seriously click that share
button take that link post it on twitter
or facebook or wherever else let people
know they can come hang out let's talk
about this first really creepy story
it's it's a it's a really really creepy
story because we have a bunch of
different outlets that have reported
this
did agents raid the home of a wrong
woman over january 6th riot maybe
that's the creepiest thing about the
maybe this story from the hour isn't the
only outlet that said maybe they did a
bunch of other outlets did i think even
the ap was like they might have but if
you go to anchorage daily news
apparently one of the only outs that
actually looked into this story they
have a photograph of the woman during
during the january 6 rally in which
trump was speaking in dc and a photo of
the woman the fbi was actually looking
for here's a funny thing okay so maybe
they're of similar age and their hair is
kind of similar the woman whose home was
raided as they were looking for nancy
pelosi's laptop was wearing a gray scarf
and i guess some kind of like low-cut or
v or open-necked shirt and the woman
they're actually looking for has big
hoop earrings and is not wearing this a
gray scarf and has some kind of i don't
know weird flower pattern shirt clearly
not the same person
so how is it that the fbi hasn't been
able to figure out who stole the laptop
they've been able to figure out who was
planting pipe bombs
what are they doing i guess tracking
down bumbling dotards who walked and
confused
so here's where it gets really crazy
apparently in this court filing
they mentioned that it was an
alaska airlines employee who
got into an altercation with these
people because they weren't wearing
masks they got banned and then i guess
this is where it gets weird someone from
alaska airlines looked up this woman's
social media account saw a post a few
days later
about being in dc on january 6 not in
the capitol mind you just
not in the capitol building just there
because trump was giving was was
rallying then called the fbi and tipped
them off and that was grounds for the
fbi to go to homer alaska and break this
woman's door in and then go and search
for a laptop
all right did they find it of course
they didn't because this was the wrong
woman and now all these these these
outlets are saying like maybe it was the
wrong woman okay you know what fine
let's play the maybe game maybe this
woman shows up in dc to hear trump speak
and then everybody decides to go into
the capital so she takes off her jacket
puts on takes off her scarf throws it
away puts on a totally different shirt
attaches new earrings all within the
span of
you know a couple hours i guess while
people are outside marching around i
just find the whole thing just
ridiculous and uh
i don't know man it makes me a bit
pessimistic because it feels like the
doj at this point has become completely
politicized and i'll tell you what
this is going to sound totally unrelated
but it really freaked me out
we grilled today we made burgers they
were delicious
they were local farm burgers apparently
the local farms were telling us that or
so we were told by local farmers
the fda's put restrictions on their
ability to sell beef until recently and
i'm like i didn't hear that how come
that's not in the news how come how come
these stories aren't in the news it
really does feel like a whole bunch of
weird and wacky stuff is happening right
you've got something going on with this
this arizona audit of the election the
fbi flying to some woman's home in
alaska desperate to find a laptop they
can't figure out where it is we've got
weird stuff with the dollar
i don't know man it all seems unrelated
but it's all to me it's indicative of
like a rot in the foundation of the
system yeah when you say weird things
with the dollar like it's terrifying
explosive inflation that's like
devastating the economy and that's not
being talked about so i'm not overly
shocked that other weird stuff is going
on too it just feels like it's breaking
apart dude
uh
let's ring the alarms the fbi can kick
your door down if they think you're
someone even if you just kind of look
like somebody is that was that where
we're at i'm not surprised that they
could do this they can get a warrant
from a judge and then go do it it's just
it's i
i'm like i'm just at this point we're
watching all this news every day i mean
we were sitting here before we pulled up
the story and i'm just like i don't even
care i don't even i don't i don't even
know what's going on anymore dude it's
like i can tell you a million and one
things but i can tell you one thing is
that
antifa goes and throws rocks through
windows and bashes skulls whatever
happened to that that old man in in
kenosha got his head bashed in by
samantha
nobody get arrested for that nothing
happened oh but some lady
gets her it's a door kick denver i i i
see that i see chauvin i see these these
these cases i see the juror lying and
i'm just like
who has confidence in the us government
at this point
aspects of it what about what are you
gonna say i mean how do you decide what
to pay attention to do you feel like
you're feeding
like
because we are engineering
you know consciousness by what we're
covering what we're talking about and so
but you like you need to go towards the
rot
but you kind of need to balance that out
i mean i'm reading
the general news right
so when i when i look at news stories
i'm looking at like all of these
different stories and i'm
ignoring a lot of things i think you
know things i don't care about so i
don't know stories about celebrity
gossip and a lot of stories about like
some instagram model where a bikini to
the beach and then it's like front page
news and a bunch of outlets yeah it gets
clicks i get it
when it comes to
cultural issues political issues
i'm trying to see what is going on and
and what matters most and what's having
a big impact but admittedly
i'm only able to look at what
journalists are for the most part
already doing now we are going to be
launching a newsroom soon we'll have a
lot of we'll have some we'll start we're
going to start doing our own original
reporting but that's why i was saying
it's like i brought up the beef thing
it's seemingly unrelated but i think
it's a really good example of people not
realizing that
i think we're being distracted by a lot
of this stuff and what i mean is this
fbi thing is scary it's creepy
the the an alaska airlines employee
sending in a tip to the fbi about a
woman because of a mask altercation
that's just like really creepy like
stuff
like what was she doing pulling up this
woman's instagram because she was mad at
her or something like that it's weird
and then the fbi goes and goes to her
house and kicks the door and looking for
nancy pelosi's laptop this is like out
of a bad action movie
so this is this this is some of the
biggest news that you hear the
mainstream media talking about what's
going on with january 6th oh they rated
this woman's home and it was like
1984 level snitch on your neighbor's
stuff which is just very strange
but then i hear this i i hear this today
when we're like we're going we're like
let's grab burgers and we'll we'll grill
and have some burgers they're delicious
by the way local beef and then
apparently the farmers are like oh yeah
we weren't allowed to uh to actually
sell any of this for a while the fda
wouldn't let us and i'm like
what
yeah it's like raw milk i mean
just no but it's something to do with
the lockdowns sometimes it was the
lockdowns it was coved and so
what i'm saying is we do have these
really creepy weirdo stories in the
mainstream media and it's really
frustrating actually when you hear like
the juror in the chauvin trial not only
did he lie about the protest he lied
about his shirt he's wearing the the
george floyd shirt and he's like i don't
remember wearing that and there's a
video of him wearing it from a different
time from like months earlier or like
months later or something like that and
so
you see we see all the stuff and that's
like
where the focus is when it comes to
politics but we're not paying attention
to is regulatory stuff what's going on
have you noticed a huge shortage of a
ton of different goods
first of all lumber's already expensive
steel's expensive food is skyrocketing
but it's not just that yeah bacon's gone
going up we couldn't find it you
couldn't find bacon yeah we went to
costco the other day and we couldn't
find any bacon and we're like what's
going on okay we're in trouble things
get real is when you can't find the
stuff yeah i'll tell you what i did i
ordered a bunch of bacon i put in our
deep freezer smart yeah because you know
when the apocalypse comes should they
say in the in the land of a broken
economy the man with bacon is king i
want to mess i could see a pig here to
be honest a pig
they're like dogs kind of ian will get
way too attached dude you'd be my best
friend yeah just get a pig and don't
kill it i think people just keep it
around it'll be good no it's just it's
just it's weird stuff that people aren't
paying attention to uh i tried buying
cat food
couldn't do it well why it took like a
like a month and a half two months to
get cat food wow yeah so uh we ended up
getting this cat food that bucko doesn't
like huh this reminds me of if this
if we were living on the titanic and
this is the part of the movie where
they're like uh this is when everyone
should be getting on live posts but we
don't have enough lifeboats so don't
freak everybody out cause there'll be a
mad dash and people will smash and kill
you so they're not telling us to get on
the lifeboats i've got huge news oh what
do you guys remember when crowder sent
me that gun yeah okay so i'm going to
tell everybody the story of what
happened with with with crowder send me
this gun actually
yeah
let me let me let me let me i'll get
into the story but let me just say a few
things but i got too excited there and
i'll just say
i got to lead into it better than that
instead of just going like i was good
though
i'm really excited okay hold on hold on
ian's right
uh so
i got concerned about the riots in in
you know when we were in the philly area
because it's this is the craziest thing
about new jersey i've talked about it
before it's a duty to retreat even from
your own home
like seriously if you are in your house
in new jersey they say it's a partial
castle doctrine state
and so i'm like okay what does that mean
it means if someone breaks into your
home
and you can escape you have to leave
your house and i'm like but go go where
and it's only if it's completely safe
and so then you got to argue to a court
why
it was
like complete
it was a totally safe or i'm sorry it
has to be like
in order to be totally safe you have to
leave if there's some risk to you by
doing it then they could argue
that you should have stayed in your home
or whatever but if you can safely leave
your home you have to
so i'm like i don't want to be in this
stuff i remember going to the stores and
seeing all the shortages and everything
and then thinking like
man should we
be preppers
because it's funny people like to make
fun of the preppers but the preppers
don't care i don't know if you guys have
seen like proper videos recently
yeah they don't they don't care what the
media says about them they're just like
whatever occur you know i've got i've
got a bunch of toilet paper while you
guys are fighting over it they're living
a great life growing food i mean why and
preparing growing food living on farms
and
i don't know if they think the world's
going to end tomorrow but
hey man
the dollar is
is is in pretty bad shape
but let me
let me tell you now let me now that i've
built the suspense up a little bit
enough to talk about this this this
crowder thing i got a big update on that
gun that crowder was supposed to send me
so this is like over a year ago i think
it was over a year ago yeah it was
i went on louder crowder
and i don't think i had a gun at this
point i was like doing the paperwork to
get one and so
steven was like
tim buddy we're getting you a gun and
he's like we're gonna send you the sig
m400 you know it's the cadillac of guns
and i'm like awesome dude thank you so
much
and then everybody wanted to know what
happened to it and just
no one ever heard about i've never
talked about it i've never showed us no
instagram photos just just never
happened well here's what happened
there apparently was only one gun shop
in new jersey that could do the
modifications to make it new jersey
legal because new jersey is a horrible
state for firearms
and so
crowder's a team ended up sending it to
the one shop that could take it the only
problem it was about 70 miles away from
where we were and that would mean
driving for about an hour and a half in
in in the middle of a day where i'm
working mornings and nights and on
weekends and i couldn't do it i'd have
to drive up there
fill out the next background check form
drive back home wait three to five days
because i was on a delay list then drive
back and do it again i'm like i can't do
that like i got a company to run i got
shows to do there's no point in the day
which i could leave and go do this
so
i told crowder i was like look it got
sent to a you know a shop that's too far
away from me i can't go get it well i
got a phone call today
and this shop calls me and they're like
it's been uh you know we're cleaning out
the storage room it's been about a year
and we found uh this this gun and it's
for you
that i got i got a voicemail i didn't
i didn't listen to it until afterwards
but i i get the missed call and i call
them they're like yeah you know we're
cleaning up the shop and we realized we
had this gun sitting here for almost a
year
do you still want it and i was like wow
i do want it can you send it to my ffl
and they were like sure thing
so i'm finally getting oh nice yeah so i
i checked the voicemail and there was it
was this woman and she was like if it's
been sitting here for a year and we're
supposed to charge you five bucks a day
for all it's been sitting here but
you know whatever if you don't want it
then we're gonna start charging you now
but calls back and i was like sure and i
called him back and the problem was when
we were in new jersey they had to do a
bunch of modifications to it and i was
like i can't pick this up and then you
know i i guess they theoretically could
have modified it or then shipped it out
whatever but i it just just fell off
so it's gonna it's gonna be surprised
they didn't say we can't ship it for
some stupid reason no they were totally
cool yeah yeah shout out they were they
were really cool and they're like nah we
got you man don't worry about it and so
i guess the issue was
when we were when we were there it
needed to be modified for new jersey
which was going to cost money and then
but now we're now we're not now we're
essentially between like maryland and
west virginia and so it's what was the
modification oh dude new jersey's got
like crazy rules about what you can or
can't have on a gun it's just so
arbitrary it's like
they have to make it so that when you
when you pull the trigger a flag comes
out with it's red and says bang on it
otherwise it's not legal yeah yeah it's
the only legal way to get a gun that
makes more sense so jersey yeah yeah
yeah
so we're getting it and uh anyway i got
all excited because uh unmodified
fully yeah fully on my device it's gonna
be it's gonna be like as as the sigm400
comes looking forward to seeing this
thing i've never even seen a picture of
it
i
yeah supposedly it's a cool gun looks
like a gun i think you know it was
supposed to be my first i guess and
that's gonna be like my 30th so
i i want to circle back as jen sackey
would say
to uh this this metaphor earlier i was
talking about about us looking for
lifeboats like how the government's kind
of distracting us or how we're being
distracted by the media when it's time
to get in the lifeboats yes we're being
distracted but i want to clarify my
point i i'm not necessarily uh saying it
was intentionally misleading us yeah it
may not matter i think everybody is
hyper focused on the same thing and
we're all staring off to our left and
meanwhile on the right like there's a
volcano erupting this is i have so many
so many things to say about i want to
read this nietzsche quote this is um
when nietzsche was talking about the
abyss he said beware that when fighting
monsters you yourself do not become a
monster for when you gaze long into the
abyss the abyss gazes also into you yes
and that's a big part of
uh you know the weight of of being a
journalist and doing things like what
we're doing is we cover dirty nasty
painful things to hear about and to
think about and it can make you angry it
can make you edgy
and and lose
focus on how to fix situations you know
when you're when you're surrounded by
problems all the time
yeah so sorry go ahead go ahead no no
continue okay i was just going to say
that michael tracy just tweeted
something about uh an article about
journalists who were freaking out and
breaking down constantly and crying and
i was like that's because they steeped
themselves in the anti-trump bubble and
they were just stewing in it all this
tds all the time and it like broke their
brains and there's a journalist who
commented her name's like katie or
something she's like my brain broke
during the trump election i was like
dude whose fault is that like no one is
making you
dive into this stuff and just swim
around in this cesspool of horrible
thoughts about donald trump all the time
you know yeah so you're right about that
can you imagine the nightmares these
people were having dude i'd love i'd pay
to see one of their nightmares soon
you'll be able to if this neural network
that's right yeah yeah there's a neural
net thing that can like decode brain
images like what you're seeing and then
it trans like transcodes it to like a
visual you know approximation i'm just
imagining you know these people all day
every day just
they were talking about after trump got
banned they were celebrating and a bunch
of people like conservatives were like
that's crazy they would celebrate the
censorship of a sitting president
you got to understand
these people
were talking about how they would wake
up in the morning and then their phone
would like they would have a shortcut to
pull up donald trump's twitter to read
what he was saying all day everyday it's
all they ever did because their
companies wanted him to do it they're
like we got to write about what trump is
trump is doing because trump makes us
money
i just imagine these people having like
you know we talked about the other day
brian stelter having a nightmare where
he's like in an old rickety house and
then he's like it's like there's like
lightning strikes and then there's trump
you can see him flashing and then he's
like
and then when he runs out the back door
it actually just transports him back
into the front door and he's trapped in
this house and there's trump in the
shadows these people were trapped in a
trump vortex
they became the demon ultimately when
you wanna when you when a problem you
know when all you focus on is the
problem it's you can't live without it
anymore like that's that becomes part of
your identity it seems like that's
what's happening and possibly is
happening to people right now
right so so
i think it's both the uh
it's it's it's causing
and a cause of the the uh the crisis the
culture war
so
the more the crisis escalates in terms
of the fbi raiding someone's home or
antifa setting buildings on fire
the more you will get say msnbc lying
about riots
and then in turn conservatives saying
the media is lying they're fake news and
so it's just a spiral that's spinning
faster and faster and faster with
everyone trapped inside do you think the
censorship of trump is working to
actually
have people talk about it less
um
talk about trump less talk about trump i
think i think it is kind of working
i think trump chose to kind of back off
for us for a couple months that's the
scary thing about censorship is it does
work
it can work in an isolated system
so within the mainstream media network
the big tech social media network i mean
yeah you can stamp it out of those but
then you know it it still has a life
outside of there but it can be hidden
i don't think censorship works it's not
true donald trump just wasn't doing
anything for a few months he was just
playing golf then he started sending out
emails again and then all sudden they
kept talking about again and even when
trump wasn't saying things they were
still talking about trump nonstop they
were impeaching the guy
they are the ones who don't want him to
let him go now trump launched from the
desk of donald trump and then people
have created social media accounts that
are just reposting what trump is posting
on his own site and twitter's banning
them all yeah probably because we're in
a less isolated environment now with the
internet because like
the romans when they conquered the gauls
this guy versus generics like they just
basically stamped that all record of
those people they censored it away and
tartaria and all this ancient asian
cultures that are just we don't even
know what they are because they were
erased let's
let's clarify something real quick
when people say that censorship works
and you look at how it affects modern
political discourse it works in the
sense that you hide certain things but
it doesn't make them go away so
has the the the the tensions between the
culture war
has it stopped no it's gotten
substantially worse but they banned all
these right-wing individuals and these
conservatives these trump supporters
yeah well they still exist and they
still believe things what happened was
these journalists are sitting on twitter
rocking back and forth like scratching
their head until their skin until
they're bleeding and then finally
twitter says we banned those people and
they go
they're gone they're finally gone and
they're just literally still sitting
there it's just all twitter did was like
pull down the blinds
they're literally still there no you can
feel the cultural tension building up
because of all this stuff
so
it's the the pressure cooker is
pressure cooker's on max yeah
that's me worried man that's why i was
like that's why when you were talking
about life boats i thought about the gun
and crowder yeah the key is i think when
you look at this nietzsche quote you
really let it seep into you if you stare
at the problem all day it will you will
become part of the problem you have to
to not i mean it's good to know what the
problem is but you got to find a
solution i don't uh i don't think it
means you will be comments just be
careful that you you don't some great
people can probably stare into it their
entire life and not become the demon but
i think there's a tendency too
so you know this alaska airline thing
really unsettled me because it reminded
me not of 1984 which is technically
fiction but of actual historical events
like during the soviet union
up those nice people who just silently
stopped by while their neighbors were
rounded up they didn't want to think
about politics they just wanted to go
about their day and then they would turn
in their own neighbors this is what gina
carano got in trouble for she was right
i just heard a number that said that in
the soviet union two and five people
were informants for the state yes that
meant that somebody in your family was
an informant and you couldn't talk about
anything so you talk about censorship
working get people in your family
involved on the government payroll see
you know why they had to round people up
and send them to gulags ian
because a censorship wasn't working
that's true they had shut down any
anti-state media
out it was all propaganda but people
still
were talking and spreading information
and then these informants would go to
the state and be alike did you hear they
were just saying these things all right
well censoring isn't working send them
to the gulag
gotta excise them from sight was the
only way because when you when when you
cut out a man's tongue you're not
proving him wrong you're only proving
you are scared of what he might say
that's a game i'm pretty sure it's a
game of thrones
what's the character uh tyrion yeah yeah
i thought
i thought you were saying today in your
in your video about contra points was
really interesting how
you know sort of the left is calling out
the free speech warriors
and the right is calling out the social
justice warriors but realistically
it's
i think that those two things do exist
and they're sort of both hypocritical on
both sides but then there are elements
of the right and left and center who are
more nuanced and i think that that's
where we all hope that we sit but it's
like
the
i think that both sides are right to a
certain degree sure sure but you look at
the new york times data they recently
did this thing where they said
38 of democrats are in a bubble
surrounded only by democrats no exposure
to conservatives but it's something like
19 percent of republicans are in a
bubble with no exposure to democrats so
that means that there are conservatives
who
uh conservatives are less likely to be
in a bubble and not understand democrats
it makes sense because the the old
saying is that uh conservatives think
liberals are misguided but liberals
think conservatives are evil to your
point
here's what we see
there is a rule
when you in the culture where when you
look at the left that when a
conservative gets censored they laugh
they gloat and they celebrate
then you will see the rule on the right
that people will immediately defend the
conservatives who get censored
when the leftists get censored it is a
rule that they will scream it is unfair
at censorship and the conservatives are
claiming they're the ones getting banned
and it is still a rule that
conservatives will defend the left when
they get censored
so
when the left gets censored the right
and the left scream censorship is wrong
when the right gets censored the left
laughs and mocks the right and the right
says is wrong you don't think there are
elements of the right that laugh when
people on the left get banned because
they think it's like karma that's
different yeah so it's one thing when
the left says dude facebook's a private
business if they want to ban you they're
allowed to and then a conservative goes
you got banned i thought you said it was
a private business serves you right
there's a difference
but there are people on the right that's
why i said it's it's uh
the exception on the left are those who
would defend a conservative when they're
censored and the exception on the right
is those who would mock the left when
they got censored yeah i think that's a
good ratio and then there's the
disaffected liberals and moderates who
are pretty principled straight through
i mean the reality is that it's hard to
defend free speech in an absolute sense
it's because you're put into a position
where you're defending horrible ideas
it's like this burden that you have to
carry around i constantly feel that but
you have to just keep walking
because
we we don't have anything other than our
principles but then you know i'm not
even going to claim to be perfect
because there are exceptions you know
there are exceptions which is the harsh
reality
you know legality there's legality and
then there's free speech in the pure
philosophical sense there's law and
there's philosophy it's it's interesting
in that we didn't necessarily have to
deal with a lot of the creepy stuff on
the internet when it came to public
discourse
like
you know people would go out in the
street and they'd show pictures of like
dead fetuses and stuff
and but for the most part you don't have
people walking around with
you know holding up big signs with like
pornography and stuff on it now on
social media people can just spam a
button and flood a network with garbage
and crap and that makes it really
difficult for regular people to engage
in a platform and have this kind of
speech when they're drowned out i
suppose in reality though
the the issue might actually just be
anonymity
and uh or uh a lack of proximity
why won't someone show up to city hall
carrying you know big posters of you
know pornography
uh because they'd have to be there
holding it themselves and then people
would see them and judge them and they'd
feel bad and be worried about their
access to resources
when it comes to social media they use
an anime avatar or you know a cat person
or something and then they can post
whatever they want no one knows who they
are right but the paradox is that when
you're anonymous you feel the true
freedom to express what you want to say
because that's exactly what i'm saying
yeah yeah so people post weirdo pictures
and creepy nonsense and garbage and they
flood the zone with trash but so so it's
simultaneously the problem but it's also
what gives us free speech because when
you have anonymity like yeah it causes
people to go crazy and like spam with
like crazy insane stuff
but it also is like a very important
fundamental human right like arguably if
you have a totalitarian government and
you need to you know organize uh a
response to it and you if you do it if
they know who you are you're dead but if
you have anonymity you can do it
functionally yeah like when antifa went
out and burned down uh burn set fire to
vehicles and threw bricks through
windows and the cops couldn't do
anything about it because they were all
wearing masks exactly it's true but i
was thinking more about the arab spring
but yes for good or ill you can organize
safely with anonymity i'm into every
history is written by the victors man uh
that
in in these countries where they have
these revolutions
when the when the revolution wins the
revolutionaries are the good guys if
they lose they were insurgent terrorists
and they were suppressed except for
castro because we had media now we have
tv and radio so we can remember how uh
what was that guy's name che guevara
putting the bullet in the guy's head or
the girl's head that image do you ever
see that shake river image we're like we
love che guevara people wear his shirt a
shirt with his face on it he was a
psychotic murderer i mean he was a
murderer he was he was a cold-blooded
murderer but the motorcycle diaries was
a sick movie
is that about him yeah
it's actually good movie so there are
the history is written by the victors
but maybe the victors were the ones that
built the internet yeah but listen
uh uh we have history of shea being a
bad person because we aren't socialists
because our our government was
anti-socialist so we made sure that that
kind of stuff existed
but
history is written by the victors man if
the activists win it was it was funny
what did uh
jack posobik tweeted today will be
called like what is he called the age of
dumb yeah
and um and i said
yeah but if the left wins it'll be
called the age of new enlightenment
it'll be the great awakening the great
awokening when people finally realized
what was truly happening
that's what that's what it'll be
but where are the history books what
what what are going to be the history
i know but in a thousand years what are
people actually going to reference
what do you mean like wikipedia
that or
something more immutable potentially
like a blockchain or databases that
can't be tampered with right or if you
see them tampered with you know they
were tampered with exactly i don't i i
disagree i mean there will be both we're
going to exist in both worlds there's
going to be encyclopedias on you know
that are immutable and then there's
going to be ones that are controlled by
centralized authorities
yeah but the centralized authorities for
now control the dominant narrative it's
interesting though uh you know i like
that that phrase if if uh if if the
situation was hopeless the propaganda
wouldn't be necessary
and
i mean uh among my three channels we get
you know i think 50 to 60 million views
per month it's down a bit because i used
to do three more segments every day i
cut those out and i cut off weekends but
we're still hitting around 50 million
and so it's not the same as you know cnn
on youtube gets 200 million but i think
that's pretty good
the net videos over the course of your
life because you'll live longer because
you're wrestling a little bit more
you'll you'll still put out the same
kind of guy no
the idea is to build something and
expand and get other people you know
empower other people to start doing
similar things like this and so i think
there's some optimism there that a show
like this can exist the problem is
they've been going after steven crowder
like crazy and it's never it's it's not
for legitimate things so you know
crowder has one of the biggest i i guess
we can call it counter culture shows he
is a conservative personality very funny
with millions of fans and subscribers
and
uh
he challenges the establishment he you
know and he questions the official
narratives and so what do they go after
him for
out of context uh edgy jokes or just
edgy jokes in general or they just make
things up like when he was quoting cdc
data they said oh that's misinformation
so they take his videos down and then
they boot him from the partner program
so they're trying really hard to it's a
culture war man how much does it cost to
launch a network
channel
do you think
what do you mean in terms of getting
like a channel on
you know
tv
i don't know um
let me think
i don't think it's that much maybe 20 to
50 million something for the alternative
media to consider but why do you want to
be on tv i don't know because maybe
maybe it's not even that much to be
honest yeah i would be that's why i'm
asking it might not be worth it but i
think at this point it's probably dirt
because what's the point
yeah
well
the point is that i think there are
millions of people who are still in that
world that like the newer generation is
not in that world but the you know i
don't know what the numbers are
i think uh
a lot of people are are watching
digitally tv ratings are in the gutter
and we are going to see in the next five
to ten years a major switch to to
digital who controls
like getting a channel
it's it's it's the and you negotiate
with the providers so like you would go
to comcast
and then say we want our channel to be
on your you know list right and then
you'd work out a deal and typically how
it works is like they give you a few
cents per household or whatever so you
use a lot of money for for some of these
channels but then you got to produce
content and so a lot of what we're
seeing now is this is amazing
mtv for instance they just do reruns of
ridiculousness
i love it advice land or vice tv or
whatever they're calling it these days
vice was supposed to have their own
cable channel and they finally got it
they just started doing reruns of movies
you'd like turn on vice and it would be
like you know groundhog days on yeah
that's a good example of
it not being worth it
to get a channel because vice did it and
it's not particularly effective and no
one's gonna watch it no one's gonna
watch it two in the morning or four in
the morning so like what's the point of
all that dead space yeah tv doesn't work
like you can't just pull up you know go
through the channels on your phone i
would think that they would the
providers would start to do that so that
you could just everything through the
channels everything's on demand now
right so hulu is way more
relevant than cable tv so if i want to
watch star trek i just go to netflix or
hulu i have an opportunity to do like a
radio show they were like hey you wanted
let's do three show it's going to air at
8 00 p.m on tuesday and i was like okay
so it ran once on ap at 8 pm on tuesday
and it was never you can't get it it was
and it felt so like i was robbed like i
spent all this time recording this thing
that is not now persistent on the
internet like as a youtube video that
someone can click on the value of it
being there all the time transcends
magnitudes more value than waiting until
9 pm to see a show i wonder if this is
all the great filter you know the great
filter
you know fermi's paradox vaguely you're
familiar with no yeah yeah so the idea
being you know if uh the universe is so
vast then surely there's intelligent
life if there is how can we haven't seen
any signs of it and there's a bunch of
hypotheses about why that may be and the
great filter is one of them and that's
when a civilization reaches a certain
point and they just get filtered out of
existence right something happens to
intelligent species that they wipe
themselves out and i'm thinking like
everything we're looking at right now
um maybe it's like yeast in a in a
bottle you know just eating the sugars
and farting ourselves to death but in
reference to what you're saying about
youtube and stuff maybe it's just that
we have billions of hours of content
every single day every perspective and
at a certain point there's just too much
static it's it's like there was a period
where
everything was noise it was chaos then
we built upon it this civilization this
order and then continuing our expansion
of technology it's going back to static
to noise you know if you were to
actually look at the raw feed of youtube
like the fire hose of all the videos
being uploaded i bet it's nonsensical
gibberish and garbage it's like a seven
second video of like a chicken looking
at a camera and then a hamster just
walking around then there's like some
little kid staying at the camera
confused for three minutes and then the
family it's just a whole bunch of
nonsense no one ever sees right but it's
it's both i mean we also have so much
access like i feel like i learn faster
than i used to
i do probably not when i was a baby like
you know you learn the most when you're
a baby but the amount of information
that we're getting now is the velocity
is so high that we're probably evolving
faster in certain ways as well i think
that baby things uh i'm not look maybe
it's true like scientists get a baby i
recommend it
hold on how long how long does it take a
baby to start speaking about a year a
year and
in what way do they start speaking in a
year
just sounds that vaguely resemble in in
i think they say on average in 44 weeks
to master a a romance language if you're
a germanic or romantic speaker and 88
weeks for an east asian language like
chinese
so in one year you can be fluent
in german or french a baby can mutter
somewhere we should do a show a
challenge of like a super smart person
versus a baby
no i'm learning a language yeah for a
year it's it's it's it's not that you
know people always say this like oh it's
so easy to pick up when you're a kid
well it's because you're not doing
anything also your brain is lit up like
they do studies fmri exams on people
with lsd and their entire brains light
up and they're active like the right and
the left hemisphere once and that's how
baby brains are
they haven't learned well they're trying
to filter stuff out trying to learn
learning
there's such high demand and need for
them to communicate because it's your
fir when it's your first language like
your body is forcing you to figure it
out so that you can achieve certain
things that you want to achieve which
you don't
have that need when you already know one
language that's not true
depending on where you live yeah maybe
you move somewhere and you have to
exactly that's true and you'll pick up
the language super very true and so i
was reading it says on average it's 44
weeks
i don't know what this study was i read
it on reddit or something to master if
you speak a germanic or romance language
in 44 weeks you can be fluent in another
language if you are actively pursuing
and speaking and using that language
let's launch the study
well i mean i guess they are interesting
how long does it take for a child to get
to the point where they're having a
conversation like this probably
four
years old i mean four years they can be
discussing discussing the nuance of
economic policy probably the smartest
kid in the world i would argue could
keep up i think a smartest four-year-old
on the planet there you go like uh
10 or 11 maybe they're having a
conversation but mostly asking questions
due to their lack of exposure to
information and context so it's not an
issue of ability it's an issue of just
time yeah you know we've had more more
more time to to learn things and
understand i mean there are videos
there's one video of this uh
chinese boy playing chopin uh fantasy
impromptu he's three i'm telling you
this
it's madness i mean it's probably he's
been trained by his parents in a very
borderline abusive way i don't want to
accuse anything but
it's insane and that's something that
none of us could do and it might take a
decade to learn so
you know there are but that's the
exception let's get back to talking
about the apocalypse yeah yeah we're
talking about how do we how do we start
talking about we're talking about yeast
farting itself to death right in a pea
tradition i think this mass influence of
information is causing interference in
our under in our ability so that's the
static is this weird influence in tide
pools what would happen is organisms
would live at one level of the tide pool
or vertically so petri dishes are kind
of one they're only two-dimensional they
don't really have up and down you can't
really get out of it normally in a tide
pool if an area of the tide pool got too
acidic or too dangerous for these
organisms to live they would come
together and form a new type of organism
that could float up to a different
strata of the tide pool and essentially
evolve into a new organism collectively
they would come together and create a
new organism now in petri dishes you
don't see that because they're
two-dimensional they don't have anywhere
to go so they eat them they die but in
the tide pool our nature is to come
together form a new species essentially
and then move somewhere where we can
thrive
i think decentralization needs to happen
it needs to happen fast i think people
need to get out of cities i think they
need to go to more rural areas they need
to start learning how to take care of
themselves and be self-sufficient and so
we got rid of one of our we have you
know two
we have a front lawn it's this there's a
walkway dividing the lawn we got rid of
one side of it and turned it into a
garden so
we're gonna be growing a lot of our own
food
not nearly enough to sustain the amount
of people who are you know living and
working
but it's a start and i think people need
to do that we also have chickens so
we're gonna have a bunch of eggs at some
point in the next couple of months and i
think having some reliance on yourself
is really important and
getting off the grid
i don't i don't mean getting off the
grid in the sense of like disappearing
from society i mean having well water
with a filtration system and having some
kind of
you know at-home renewable of solar or
wind or whatever you can get and
still being attached to the grid just
having the capability to survive on your
own in the event
things start falling apart yeah the
electric grid especially right because
right now if one part of the electric
kit goes down they shut the entire grid
down to repair it and take everyone's
power out it's not sustainable or
there's a storm and it could knock out
your power and what are you gonna do so
i'm thinking about what we're seeing
with the market um there's there's
desperate attempts to assuage the fears
of an impending market collapse and
hyperinflation
and
i i think it's coming i think we're
starting to see a lot of the same signs
far be it for me to tell anybody what
they should do with their money but you
know i've been talking to a lot of my
friends who are uh you know some of them
who do
are day traders and work in investment
firms and they they bring up you know
every time we see a major collapse
you start seeing similar signs of the
media saying oh no everything's fine
there's no collapse just keep doing your
thing and it's like
when they start saying this stuff
everything's okay go back to work do
mind your own business
it happens every time and then there's a
major collapse or some kind of crap
there was a case uh i was meant talking
about christopher mellon who was just on
rogan like a couple days ago and he told
this story where because this guy worked
in intelligence agencies they told him
that there was a pending nuclear attack
on new york and dc
and they told and so he had his whole
when when when uh i don't remember what
year he said but he but he was told from
the inside that this is likely to be
happening and so he like told his family
and friends but like he said he was
walking around sort of in a blur because
he you know it was surreal he felt like
he should warn people but it would cause
more chaos that's why they but that did
happen that's confirmed from the inside
they knew nuclear was a was a tangible
threat and they decided not to tell
anyone because they figured it out they
didn't they didn't have years ago five
years ago 10 years ago if maybe lydia
can help look up the the date but like
during the i mean i think he might have
even broken the news like two days ago
so i'm not sure but
you know they didn't have full
confirmation that the attack was coming
so they decided that it wasn't worth it
because their level of intelligence
wasn't guaranteed and then luckily it
ended up not happening that's why i
think
you know the preppers are laughing at us
because they're like you got these
arrogant city folk mock preppers and
it's just like
first of all why do i care what you
think about me second of all when you
when when the water shuts off the power
goes out like when hurricane sandy hit
and the power went out in new york
it would hurt like no none of these
proper people care when there's a
hurricane like and they got everything
they could they're they're they're good
they go underground the joke's on the
people mocking it's really yeah they're
not they're not preparing like preppers
truthers like when i remember when
truther became a word that was like a
pejorative i mean that's
that's out of a fiction novel truther i
mean granted okay there are there are
some like crazy truthers about certain
topics but like the fact that the phrase
truther is used as a pejorative
is insane when you just look at it from
the outside i'll tell you what's insane
there was that quote from joe biden
recently where he's like who needs a
hundred rounds what do you think the
deer is wearing kevlar
it's like uh
your life has been so cushy and soft
you've been such a spoiled pampered brat
because you do not know hardship that
you're like why would anyone ever need
to defend their lives
well i guess you can ask the the the the
people in inner city chicago why they
keep buying illegal guns and bringing
them in and buying them
because there's a lot of gun violence
and they're worried some people are bad
people and want to commit crimes and
some people are worried about being the
victims of crime but that statement from
joe biden just shows that's the
mentality they've never had hardship
imagine spending your whole life you
know i'll put this way i know a lot of
people who never had jobs this crazy 26
27 year olds never had a job wow why
they went to school they went to high
school they went to college went to a
master's program get out 24 to 26 never
had a job ever
so they have no idea how anything works
they have no idea how to get money
and they're just men adults at 26 who
don't know how to survive on their own
now that is obvious you can see that you
can be like obviously if you've never
worked and never you know generated
income you're going to be a 26 year old
with all of life's responsibilities out
of school and having no idea what to do
sure they can teach you how to play the
trombone in college or they can teach
you how to like you know set up a
nuclear reactor but they don't tell you
how to get a job or make money or or you
know set up a banking account or pay
your taxes
and now you think about that and think
about conflict and crisis
not not not a person in this country
save
cops
veterans and not even every veteran a
lot of them are administrative a lot of
cops are administrative
there's a relatively small fraction of
people in this country who have actually
experienced any kind of real conflict so
most people in this country are voting
based on the the idea that everything is
and always will be fine because
it is normal to not have to worry about
any of these things
it's normal yeah and that's why
decentralized decentralization is
something you're sort of forced to learn
whether it's digital decentralization or
physical you know with farms and stuff
like you have to get banned in in order
or you have to know people who are
getting abandoned
in order to understand that you need to
secure yourself and your communication
system that's why it's funny when you
you know i was talking about contra
points earlier on one of my channels
contra points is a leftist who
if you if you look at her twitter
accounts i search for free speech
there's just mockery of the free speech
warriors
now all of a sudden after one of her
videos his age restricted it's we must
stand up for free speech and the left
must reclaim free speech and it's like
my response is always thank you welcome
to the fight please your advocacy for
free speech is greatly welcomed but if
only you stopped treating this like a
like a joke in a game and that's the
point people who weren't being oppressed
the people who weren't being targeted by
a system who did not know hardship were
laughing at those who were saying we
need to be prepared and fight this
because they weren't experiencing the
problems this is the funny thing now
you you can you can see something so
plainly obvious what do you do when the
power goes out i don't know the power it
ever goes out if it does someone fixes
it for me
what do you do when the power goes out
and doesn't come back on
what are you some kind of dumb prapper
okay well listen
you can keep betting on this idea that
life is and always will be a golden age
just for you or you can look at history
and recognize for one golden ages come
to an end and two the natural state of
life on this planet is constantly
stressed out running and struggling to
survive i did play a game of sieve where
i went from golden age to golden age to
golden age to golden age for like
thousands thousands of years
what was your strategy i don't know i
was playing on easy uh
it was cultural science based
culture and science yeah
yeah you were playing easy mode i think
i was playing like normal like prince or
something above average not hard not
super hard i think it's the same reason
people sit on big tech apps
because they have no reason to leave i
mean they haven't experienced what
people involved in these issues have
experienced they're not you know real
journalists who have
experienced censorship in international
countries i'm talking about
international journalists who are like
you know really getting censored by
governments and whatnot and so
you know you have to experience it you
see that really this really great video
from last year where someone from the
bbc is interviewing the president of
azerbaijan and they're like your your
record on the on press freedom is
important and he was like what about
julian assange and then it's just like
mike drop he's like you've had this guy
locked up for how many years holding him
up holding it holding him as a hostage
and then you're gonna talk to us about
press freedoms and she's like well i'm
not holding on to your country is doing
it so don't come to me and criticize me
and it's like
i'm pretty sure they have very bad track
record on journalism so they don't get
any free passes but why should the uk
why should you know any one of these
these these countries or the the us even
pretend that they're doing well now keep
in mind i love when the left claims like
press freedoms in the u.s under trump
slipped worse than somalia or whatever
stupid garbage they were saying
what you have now
there was there was a tweet from this
journalist
and she was like i ordered a bulletproof
vest that i need for doing journalism in
america and it was too small and i was i
was at one point kind of glad it was too
small that my bulletproof vest that i
need for journalism in america wasn't
gonna fit me and i'm like it's too big
she was
she was too small yeah it was too big
for her uh the point is
the the the she was clearly trying to
make a point about i can't believe
people in america would need to wear a
bulletproof vest
what do you think the world is like
this is like someone living in a chuck e
cheese's in the in the bounty castle
being like why would anyone need a
helmet i guess we're in a bouncy castle
you want to protect your kids outside is
concrete like you want to protect the
minds of children like you don't want to
show them soldiers getting blown apart
and bleeding out and stuff when they're
one so that it warps their perception
but
you also don't want to coddle them and
not show them any of the terror of
reality in my opinion i don't have kids
you have kids you can probably talk
better about this than i can
um
and i don't even know like how how have
you been navigating that do you want to
talk about that on
yeah like well that's kind of what was
interesting about when we all first
experienced the internet
you know you go and you find the
craziest [ __ ] that you can find i
remember like uh
live leak videos man yeah just like oh
there's a guy getting murdered again
yeah he's like watching it and just like
wow i could rail off two girls one cup
trauma oh my gosh motorcycles hitting
people in the head i mean faces of death
remember that
yeah i don't know the answer to that i
think you need to ease
a brain into the reality but you don't
you don't want to shelter them too much
that's for sure it's tough and easy yeah
but we have a generation and we have we
have what now like three generations of
ever increasing um
padded walls
so this what's happening is now you have
all these urban liberals who
it's like wall-e you know it's like the
morbidly obese people in their hover
chairs floating around where things are
being done for them they live in these
big cities
you know what i got to say
there's a uh kovit may have been really
really bad but at least one of the
positives
because it's there's nuance in all
things i know a lot of people are going
to be like it's it's controversial to
say that there could be anything good
coming out of something bad no it's that
these people in cities are going to stop
wasting stop mass consumption and start
realizing that life takes hard work and
responsibility and you can't just sit
back and let someone else do it because
you know what happens when you do cuomo
goes and kills 15 000 people
or your guard comes in murder like they
say like when people have bunkers and
it's the end of the world and you're
relying on your hired security the hired
security is going to come kill you and
take the bunker for themself that's well
what's part of the story what's the joke
from uh somebody super chatted at us as
i said uh on behalf of all gun owners
i'd like to thank the gun control
advocates for stockpiling our goods for
us for the
apocalypse yeah what do you think's
going to happen when if slash when you
know there's a collapse
i think it's funny too there was a post
on facebook and someone mentioned
something about i think they were
talking about like dogecoin and like
this this the skyrocketing dogecoin you
got to buy this currency or buy that
currency because the dollar is in
serious trouble and then someone laughed
saying like you guys keep talking about
some kind of like disaster collapse or
civil war and they're like where is it
when's going to happen and the funniest
thing about these comments that i keep
hearing from people like where's the
civil war at bro
i'm like aren't you the people obsessed
with the storming of the capital on the
sixth
like clearly we're in the middle of
something the dollar is hyper the dollar
isn't hyper inflated but it's inflating
and the cost of goods is going way up
now the gold lumber ratio is is is you
know coming together i don't know
necessarily it's a good thing or a bad
thing but we're seeing a dramatic shift
in the economy in general and it's it's
you know the craziest thing is we've
been trying to expand out here we've
been trying to find companies so we can
fix the the the barn outside where we're
going to be doing events we can't get
anybody to do it we can't find anybody
lumber is too expensive steel's too
expensive
we're struggling to get things done and
it's really really annoying for me but
there's a shortage we tried ordering new
computer new equipment so we can improve
the people people have been saying like
the sound has issues on the show like we
got to get the new equipment right we
can't get it in
something is happening and there is a
shortage of goods and computer chips and
and merchandise and and all the stuff is
going down and then you have these dumb
people on the internet hyper focused on
whatever cnn tells them totally ignoring
whatever's happening around them man i
can't i can't imagine what it's going to
be like for these people when the rug
gets pulled out from underneath them
that is alarming i mean because as you
know you have resources to make these
things happen and so the fact that
someone in your position cannot
build out a barn
to become i've called like five
companies and they're like oh man you
know it's steel it's hard to get it's
really expensive right now
and i'm like can you send people out
like what do you got to do
and then and so even with like getting
the website done it's like it's it's
difficult to get things to move right
now even with like digital uh with like
software and stuff it's just
been very difficult across the board and
i remember like we uh so one of the
things one of the issues we have the
studio that we're in is the highest
point of the building and so it gets
really hot um
so we were supposed to get some kind of
like
wall-mounted ac unit that's ultra quiet
to help circulate the air and keep it
cool company just never shows up
company doesn't show up they come out
here like oh we're going to get back to
you they don't show up we had more work
being done company comes out one day
just gone the next just don't show up
and i'm like what's happening
like seriously how
i don't know that that feels like it's
quiet before the storm type situation
it really does what are people doing to
where the businesses aren't functioning
properly so i ordered a new machine for
this studio
uh
a month and a half ago when did i say
hey guys good news in a week we're going
to be getting a new machine
something i don't remember there's a
chip shortage oh yeah and so they keep
saying we're really sorry about this any
day now any dinner trust us and then
we'll get it shipped out immediately and
just nothing well i was talking to a guy
who owns a ford dealership in norwalk
and he was saying that they just cannot
get cars
i mean
unbelievable it's like you're trying to
buy the market is there
trying to buy something and
the supply is not this is existing this
is showing our softness and our like
padded walls because
it's not normal to have access to all
that stuff like that for the golden age
right right that's my point my point is
of a golden age no no my point is we
know it we're talking about it i've i've
been watching this stuff in real time so
we are
moderately prepared for some kind of
serious downturn and i think it's funny
that
even after a year of a lockdown you
still have naysayers who are like what
are you some kind of prepper it's like
bro do you remember going to the store
for toilet paper last year did do you
have amnesia
what's what's going on bro
are you looking at the price of
cryptocurrencies
dude these things aren't just going up
in value because people finally realized
that they're a technology worth using
it's because people are scared of the us
dollar right now dude you if you were on
a beach and you saw a tsunami coming
that was
thousands of feet high
how would you react and i think that's
what society people are doing in society
right now and you'd have people walking
out into the water like their brains
would break their minds actually
being out in the ocean is a safe place
to be you'd take your um surfboard and
dive it and ride it right at home well
not you don't you want to be hit by a
tsunami but when there's boats that are
a few miles out when the tsunami comes
they stay you know it goes under them or
goes past them when you're faced with
the impending destruction of everything
um how would you react and i think these
people are kind of seeing it's such a
big problem that their minds can't
calculate it and so they just ridicule
there's a there's an interesting
question i can't remember where it was
posed but they said if you were sitting
in munich city
and you saw like an icbm coming right
down about to hit your you know the
downtown area from wherever you were
which which direction would you run
and the point was that if you truly
understood the power and the range of
the icbm you would run towards it
you know why
because you'd be getting away from the
blast radius no no running towards the
explosion oh i thought you meant the
missile yeah if you saw a missile
heading towards your city depending on
how close you were to city center you
would probably want to run towards it
you know why to get vaporized to get
vaporized otherwise you can just sit
there and get radiation burns and slowly
melt and suffer for several hours by
debris so i remember i think the new
york times did this where they talked
about the the the blast radius of your
standard icbms and they like talked
about the different kinds of missiles
and there's the initial blast radius
which vaporizes everything then there's
the melt radius wherever like you would
slowly just watch yourself melt in
extreme suffering for like an hour and
then outside of that is the radiation
poisoning where you get to live for a
little while as your the your dna
fractures and cracks and then you just
suffer for a long time
so
i just bring that up to your reference
about a tsunami depending on where you
were you can accept your fate and try
and get it over with quickly or you can
run and try and survive it's tough it's
it's hard to know what to do but i think
most people would just say try and
survive always no matter what but when
you're faced with something where
there's no survival is not an option and
you're just like okay there it is this
is it how do you respond do you
acknowledge it do you still logically
try and formulate a solution can you
uh uh well are you uh uh or do you just
break i think it depends on
you know you know i think it's a
rhetorical question have you ever seen
that that meme where it's a bell curve
of iq at the very back it's this like
deranged looking person who you know
seems to be kind of messed up iq 0 and
they say god is real then in the middle
it's the average iq and the person
saying i'm an atheist and then all of
the high end it's a person with a
gigantic brain saying god is real i
think it's kind of like that i think a
lot of really smart i'm not saying
religious but like a lot of really smart
uh and philosophically mature
individuals would see the the sun
exploding and the wave coming towards
them and they'd sit down and close their
eyes then you'd have a lot of really
dumb people who would probably sit down
and be like wow and they close their
eyes and then you have a lot of average
people who would be screaming and
flailing and ranting not understanding
what to do the midwits the people of
slightly above intelligence who know
just enough but not enough they know
enough to repeat what they've heard
i think they're smart
yeah it's crazy that like not even
countries are
sort of immune to all this and so i
think it'll be really interesting to see
which countries adopt crypto and bitcoin
because the ones that do
are going to lead the future that's just
a fact it's it's a more resilient
infrastructure it's better tech so if
they just ignore the problem they're
gonna they're gonna get left behind if i
was a conspiracy theorist i would if i
was to push one i would say that
they the there's special interests that
want a total collapse of the us and the
global economy so that they could have a
some kind of reset like a great resource
yeah maybe like a great reason that just
resets global capitalism with a new
system you would need a new currency and
obviously the authoritarians would want
to be able to track every transaction so
they would need some kind of like public
ledger
um like a chain of maybe like blocks
where you can see each transaction would
you call it though um well because it's
a reference to like you know computers
and chain block well no no because it's
a reference to computers but also
currency it would be something like byte
or like bit and then like money or coins
maybe like bitcoin bitcoin
yeah that's what i would call it so you
create a trackable currency and then
wipe out fiat and put everyone on the
trackable currency yeah yeah then then
you know what everyone is spending at
all times of course people would try and
create things like monero they would try
and you know uh use alternative
currencies
that uh retain value because they're uh
they can't be duplicated but uh
ultimately i think bitcoin is
i think bitcoin's gonna hit a million
bucks and i think the reason it is
because we need uh
i mean the the government would love to
have this system this global well
transfer of value
that they can easily watch and everyone
can watch and it's the panopticon
it's in
yeah there are benefits
to them but that's why they're going to
be launching their own
digital current digital currencies that
are not bitcoin because they don't
control bitcoin is the reality there are
surveillance benefits that they get from
bitcoin but they don't
bitcoin empowers the the people of the
world bitcoin it's much more if bitcoin
was not created by the government and
conspiracy that's correct
i'm i'm gonna i got i gotta i gotta stop
you right there bill and tell you um the
the currency of the people is not
bitcoin oh
here we go i'm ready
i'm ready to fight
can we get in the ring
what you don't think shibuya you don't
think it's dogecoin
i think that
it has really cool characteristics like
that's that are fun and of the people
but it's not
architecturally built for the people
it's architecturally built to screw
people over well hold on all right we'll
talk about that but let me tell you the
story
dogecoin is up 12 000
since january here's how much money
you'd make if you invested a thousand
bucks in january
if you bought dogecoin at the beginning
of the year you've enjoyed massive gains
over the past four months months a one
thousand dollar dogecoin purchase on
january first at a price of less than a
cent per coin would be worth 121
052 at wednesday's high of 69 cents a
gain of more than 12 000
my friend dogecoin let's go to the moon
it probably will be physically put on
the moon on a
on a thumb drive i would not be
surprised if he did that but hopefully
he'll also put bitcoin maybe some mines
tokens who knows that'd be great but you
you think dogecoin is is not it
it's it's it for a a purpose of
entertainment
it's a meme it's fun but it's not it for
like you know if you look at the the
code of it it's not
because it can it's inflating it's it's
not maintained it's not really
decentralized it's
it's
let's go one by one how is it not
decentralized okay so um it's like one
guy owns the main coin mining system i'm
gonna bring up a
the federal doge reserve the
government's gonna seize the guys mining
servers and then
so i'm just gonna run through like quick
bullet points on on doge so
bitcoin is scarce there will only ever
be 21 million doge is infinite the
system is on track to mend 14.4 million
new doge each day and 5.2 billion each
year forever okay
it bitcoin's issuance this is from the
student alex gladstein uh who knows a
lot about bitcoin um
bitcoin dogecoin's issue issuance is
unpredictable it can and has been
altered uh bitcoin is decentralized as a
result of robust architecture of full
nodes
um dogecoin is not decentralized bitcoin
has how is it 90 central here's the
other thing about doge people are buying
doge on robin hood look don't buy crypto
on robin hood you don't even own the
crypto they're holding it you can't even
get the crypto
if you buy it on robin hood
so
most people who are buying doge are
buying it on robin hood they don't even
actually own the crypto this is why
you have to control your own wallet like
it's fine to use centralized exchanges
to take custody of your crypto but you
need to set up your own wallet like on
mines.com if you check out um our wallet
you set up metamask you control your
keys
coinbase while you do own you do control
your keys that's a that's a
non-custodial wallet yeah but i mean
these things like so it's fun
doge is fun and it's a cool part of
what's happening like i like doge but
it's
it's not a good thing to be saying can't
they hard fork doge and then why would
you do that when you already have
bitcoin because doge
could be a currency so can
it will it is exactly right so what what
do we hear kfc now takes dogecoin
yeah oakland a's are accepting doge
should kfc dude
this is what i'm saying it doesn't
matter if it's a box of kleenex
if people have confidence that the
kleenex will get them a cheeseburger
they will clamber for but you can't have
confidence the doge is going to retain
its value you can't have confidence the
u.s dollar is going to retain you you
can have confidence that bitcoin is
going to in the long term based on the
structure and and gold and silver or
palladium or whatever
the thing about doge is that it is more
like cash
and it has the confidence of the people
for a very silly reason it doesn't
matter people want it and some people
want to just have it for the sake of
having it a lot too and that's why it's
that's what part of why it's retaining
value because a lot of people are
holding doge right and they're actually
providing the liquidity for the market
for all the whales who are dumping so
you know the bag you know the the the
retail the people are getting left
holding the bags of all the people
dumping and it's just
it's it it's a joke let it be a joke
don't like it really the the structure
it could be altered in the future to
become better like he was saying you
know it can the the code can be altered
but there's not an active development
team around doge if why not there could
be if you've got a building in the
middle of manhattan that's just falling
apart eventually someone's gonna be like
this is prime real estate
we can fix this up and make it something
better because everybody wants honestly
i hope so i hope that the development
energy around doge gets revitalized and
like you know similar in the way that
ethereum is run like so bitcoin is
arguably more decentralized than
ethereum but the cool thing about
ethereum is that it keeps innovating and
they have decentralized governance yeah
what are what are they doing now we were
just talking about the other day that in
july they're going to start
deflating the currency or something yeah
yeah they're introducing uh a new
proposal which burns uh the base
fee to the miners for all the
transactions so that so there will be a
deflationary force in ethereum that
means ethereum will just start
skyrocketing in value
who knows it would be a pressure point
the the thing about ethereum is there's
so much developer energy there's so many
decentralized apps like mines that are
getting that are leveraging the ethereum
network and we we integrate bitcoin as
well but
you know doze doesn't have that energy
it's fun but it would be nothing without
elon
let's be let's be real it would not
he is the one
he's gonna go on
people think he's going to do a dogecoin
skit it's going to hit a buck and then
the whales are going to bail out yes
so get ready for that and time it i
don't honestly sell before snl no i i
disagree well hold on hold on hold on
not financially i'm not i'm not going to
give it yeah no advice to anybody i
don't why does everyone say that cause
you get sued or something i you probably
don't have to i don't know everyone just
says it yeah it's a meme yes uh here's
what i'd say
if you can afford to keep your doge you
should
in 2014 is that one that's when doge
came out right was it 2014 i'm not sure
i had at some point i don't remember
when on some exchange i had thousands of
doge
and i was laughing how stupid it was and
now everyone was laughing and it was a
joke and it was like such currency such
crypto wow whenever it was haha memes
memes memes
and then i was like whatever and i lost
them i have no idea where these coins
are
now it's worth you know 60 cents or
whatever and i'm like it'd be sure great
to know what happened to those coins but
i said about everything i had a computer
with like bitcoin on it got destroyed
and didn't care and just threw it away
because it was like a dollar worth of
bitcoin that's not worth like a couple
hundred thousand dollars and it's all
gone
so that's why i'm like you know what
at this point
there were there there were some other
currencies that i had purchased a decent
amount of like way back in the day
because i was like at one at some point
in a few years one of these currencies
might go from like one cent to five
cents and i'll be really happy
and then i just got paper hands and i
was like
i just write that bitcoin and that's
what i talked back to bitcoin and while
bitcoin has performed beautifully over
the past several years there are some
currencies that i wish i held on to
because the gains were from like one
cent like a dollar which is way better
than bitcoin was so now i'm just kind of
like you know man
maybe maybe uh we're seeing the dogecoin
memification or whatever but i'll tell
you this i'm gonna keep it yeah yeah i
just like that you're not gonna make the
same mistake you you made the mistake
before so you don't i also don't have so
much doge that i'm gonna like become
rich off of it or or like become poor
off of it it's like maybe if i had 10
million doge or something i'd sell and
be like i don't want to play that game
right but i don't i have very little
you know most people probably only a
little bit that's sort of the thing that
is sort of a sickness in the crypto
space is actually people just trying to
get 10xs right and and they're
manipulators you know the thing that i
love about crypto is that you're sort of
voting with your resources
so i don't like to participate in tokens
that i just think that their value is
going to go up it's not
why are you giving energy to that so i'm
not saying never you know maybe there's
a place for it but
bitcoin is changing how society works
and that's why it's an amazing thing to
put your money into it because you're
you're helping that happen we should set
up doge atms
yeah
i wouldn't be surprised
no i just can't it's so fake it's such
trash it's a it's a trash coin it's the
ultimate trash coin elon musk is the
ultimate troll
yes
he's hilarious i love him and do you
think elon has like a billion dollars
yeah oh yeah he probably went his kids
are mining it oh really yeah he said i i
saw it so you said doge isn't
decentralized well it's it you know
there are miners
but so it is partially decentralized but
it's it's not nothing compared to
bitcoin so it's a variant scale of of
how decentralized is this token whenever
you're looking at a crypto right and
certain cryptos or more or less like are
there cryptos that are completely
centralized or like one person can print
that's what a digital dollar would be so
here's here's the problem i see with
bitcoin though 21 million coins can
never come into existence right yeah a
lot of them are already gone because
when bitcoin was valueless people didn't
care and lost them like that famous guy
who was searching a dumpster for a a
trash dump for his hard drive because it
had like oh man by now that hard drive
is probably worth like 100 200 million
dollars but it was like it's worth now
two million dollars he needs to go find
it that hard drive with his coins on it
so there's just the the natural decay of
bitcoin
that's good
so that's deflationary but right so over
a long enough period of time there won't
be enough bitcoin no that you just you
can split it up into 100 million units
satoshi which is the smallest unit of
bitcoin
will just
appreciate in value so
it's not i don't think that the there's
there's plenty of divisibility within
bitcoin so if bitcoin became universally
adapted around the planet with you know
eight billion people and people need to
trade with it every day then satoshi
would have to be worth somewhere around
like a nickel he has a million bitcoin
or something satoshi satoshi satoshi
right so and it's never moved it's never
moved and it's very important that it's
never moved so
well because if people started to see
the the creator
you know getting paper hands right that
wouldn't be good well so imagine bitcoin
becomes universally used right
one satoshi would have to be around the
value of a nickel or so because
you know
as it stands today to be able to
participate in the general marketplace
uh or or labor theoretically it could be
around a penny for satoshi but i think
that's
people don't really use pennies all that
much
yeah but there's a lot of countries
where a penny probably does have a lot
more value
it doesn't really matter if we're using
the smallest unit like in comparison to
you know a fiat comparable i think like
right now the the bitcoin market's like
a little over a trillion the gold market
cap for reference is 10 trillion so if
the bitcoin market just gets to what
gold is then we're at like 500k
per bitcoin so you just started you
start thinking about bitcoin is like
eating away
at where resources are are stored all we
need to do is 10x
to get at gold and then if you start
bringing in all different financial
instruments for bitcoin
if it 10x is yeah i think bitcoin will
be a million bucks oh for sure
i think sooner than people there's a
model called the stock to flow model
which is
like the model of bitcoin and it because
every four years the reward that there's
this thing called the having
which is where the mind happening or
either does it happen either people say
both but so the rewards to all the
miners drop in half so you know it's
basically more scarcity it's more
no no it's just the the the ongoing
rewards that they get for mining drop in
half so it you know they don't
necessarily sell but it just creates
more scarcity and historically there
have been two havings so far and after
each half having you know over the last
10 years you've seen a order of
magnitude
and so
the stock to flow model shows that you
know over the next 15 years
it's going to be order when's the next
happening uh it was just a couple years
ago so it's like in a couple years oh
okay so then
or maybe not a couple years it's going
to effectively double so uh people often
ask what is what what backs about
bitcoin's value and i don't know if this
is like an archaic understanding but
it's the energy used to produce it
so if somebody is mining bitcoin and it
costs them
you know sixty thousand dollars to mine
one bitcoin they're not going to sell it
for less than the cost of the production
so then they'll put it on the market and
say i gotta get at least 61k and
probably more than that
and then people who want to buy because
they want to use it are going to have to
pay the price of what the miners are
asking for yeah and it's potentially
going to do great things for sustainable
energy like people say oh bitcoin uses
so much energy it's like an
environmental disaster which it does use
a lot of energy it's it's a worth it is
it kind of arbitrary is it ethereum
better well
no it's not better or worse they're
they're different technologies for
different purposes i mean you build apps
on top of ethereum bitcoin is just like
the juggernaut
godfather of ledger for global monetary
transactions that's all that it needs to
be and there are like layer two things
happening so that there will be other
you know apps potentially on bitcoin but
you know it's
it's just crazy that this is happening
it's actually
you don't you think it's going to help
the energy situation well because people
like energy can be converted into
bitcoin so like there's you know that
if they're if you have a landfill and
there's like methane overflow like you
could potentially throw mine on top of
that i got it
you know we should do
we should
create
power plants
that recycle the heat from mining
bitcoin to boiling water and spinning
turbines
or we can put
gpus
in people's homes that mine bitcoin and
the x and their radiant heat will heat
their room it's called it's called
exergy it's an actual project yeah where
your computer eats water tanks we were
just talking bill and i actually visited
a guy in new york that was working on
this and um then the tubes will go
through your house these hot water to
cool down
warm so cool the house well so you need
you need to cool your computer your your
cpu and your gpu need to be cooled and
so
the heat we want for warmth the computer
wants the cold so hey there you go a lot
of people say like facebook has servers
in the arctic
dude that heat is valuable you just need
to recover it yeah yeah people want to
heat their homes let's just do it with
uh with bitcoin mining so in in winter
you make money you're like oh it's
getting gold better make some bitcoin
crank it up yeah no there i i predict
mining rigs in this in this compound in
the next few years this compound i don't
think so no why
it's easy just throw up a comp you know
have fun
yeah but you can figure it there's
there's there's an roi so what's
ethereum is proof of stake though how do
they how do you generate well they're
not proof of stake yet right so they're
transitioning if the ethereum
blockchain's still proof of work like
bitcoin so these miners so how many
ethereum are there how much ethereum is
there
some people
it's harder to pinpoint the exact supply
um in ethereum it is it is sort of
limited i don't know the actual number
and a lot of people criticize ethereum
for that reason
but that doesn't mean that it's like
very inflationary just the way that it's
set up it's it's harder to pinpoint the
ex the exact numbers at any given time
but
um you know they are they're they're
bringing in this deflationary force but
proof of stake is basically where
there are validator nodes all over the
world that people run the machines you
can run on your laptop and if you have
32 eth
you can stake
that eth into that validate validator
node and
basically earn it generates more
ethereum it just yeah you earn you earn
ethereum for for staking eth into what
is validator nodes is it generating it
or is it a tr is a fee that you're
getting from the existing amount of
ethereum
both
well your j miners
i'm i might be wrong here but miners are
earning fees for all the transactions
that are happening in the network that's
gas and ethereum and bitcoin miners
actually in bitcoin after all of the
mining rewards are over which is in like
100 years or something then fees are
going to be
uh rewarding all of the miners but
that's how it works in ethereum now but
there are there are also ethereum that
are are getting created
as well so it is both and look in here
it says that there is where there's 18
million bitcoins there's 115 million
ethereums and 129 billion currently
right now yeah 115 million seven hundred
and sixty eight thousand there's already
eighteen million bitcoin yeah eighteen
million yeah
but it's going to take like a hundred
years to finish it because it gets
harder right
underneath the ethereum it doesn't have
like it has a scale of how far along how
many of them have been built although
you're saying it takes longer the closer
you get to the fine final point um it
doesn't have one for ethereum i'm at
coinmarketcap.com this is where i go to
check out the crypto lists um it doesn't
say so ethereum doesn't they don't say
how many they're going to print in the
long run
no i don't think so but they also have a
deflationary force in it so it's pulling
the supply down how stupid are these
nfts man
how stupid is art you can make
yeah certain cases you are like
christie's like the famous auction house
is actually
combining the physical art with the nft
along with it which is sort of like a
certificate of ownership of the physical
art right so you can combine them
did you ever see the beer bottle that
had if you used your smartphone over it
and it scanned it it became like a movie
like the the image on the beer bottle
label would animate and start moving no
if you had a crypto token that could
give you that authorization so if you
moused over you went over like a piece
of art and you had that nft token you'd
be able to see the movie but what i mean
is a lot of people were like i'm gonna
buy this piece of art on the internet
and then like a day later it didn't work
anymore because the server that was
hosting it was going oh yeah yeah yeah
nft was just so so that can be fixed so
nfts are like a token on a blockchain
that reference they can reference a a
piece of art or a file
so depending on where the token on the
blockchain is referencing that file like
you can reference the file on our weave
or ipfs or different like decentralized
immutable file systems as well like but
there are a bunch of nfts that are
referencing like amazon so if it goes
down then the nft yeah you see the
disaster girl meme no oh yeah yeah so
she sold it yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's
like you know the photo was like fire's
a little girl and she's like smiling at
the camera she sold it for like 470k
yeah was it her photo was it her
family's photo
do they get the rights to the photo now
they could distribute it right did she
just take it did someone else take the
photo and then she just
like it was hers it's someone by the
ownership of the photo meaning that they
can license it out now to
news outlets who want to use it it's a
good question i mean there's a copyright
chaos that is coming with nfts because
people are are acting like it represents
ownership of stuff that they probably
don't actually know but the thing about
nfts is that
they can be used for other things like
they could be used for an insurance
product and nft is just a non-fungible
token right which is just one of it as
opposed to fungible tokens like mines
tokens mines.com token uh which you know
you can create a token and there are
many of one yeah and they all they're
all they're interchangeable so when you
think about like financial markets
depending on the type of asset a a
non-fungible might make more sense so
like the idea in itself does make sense
the craziest thing with uh with ethereum
why i think ethereum is
well let me let me slow down bitcoin is
probably gonna be worth a ridiculous on
a ridiculous amount of money because
it's digital gold it's a it's a digital
asset that can't be copied and it's a
way to store value ethereum has
functions that people don't even realize
yet
so what's interesting um you mentioned
minds tokens
there are a lot of social networks um
you know we've we've uh been sponsored
by pocketnet in the past and they have
their own kind of cryptocurrency and
their decentralized social network but a
lot of these other uh i've had
conversations with other networks i'm
not going to name them because i don't
want to get you know get anybody mad or
you know deride anyone but i'm like okay
so you're a social media site and you
have a cryptocurrency what does it do
and they can't give me an answer if you
if you produce content on the site you
get access and i'm like right what does
a token do you can trade it for money
why would anyone want it how i trade it
to someone for what it's speculation
because someone might want to hold it
can become no okay i don't know what
that's all about minds on the other hand
a token is how you buy views it's how
you boost posts you buy ads right so the
value of a mind token and my nds is
predicated upon the robustness of the
mind's audience
so if you sell i don't know communist
pillows
and minds has you know millions upon
millions of users
i would like to get my ridiculous
communist pillow in front of these
individuals i need a minds token to be
able to purchase that yeah we've been
all about grounding it in real tangible
value so like actually
in addition to that when you help stake
liquidity into the network you get
passive boosts so there's this like
special boost slot on the main news feed
on the sidebar that all it does is
rotate liquidity providers
so everybody who's in that is gets based
on their share of the liquidity pool
gets rotation
basically free advertising so yeah i
mean it's all about real value this
makes sense why would someone want a
minds token well if you would like to
buy if you'd like to boost your content
so you can get more followers and build
a following if you would like to get
more views in your content which in turn
cannot be generate more tokens
you buy the tokens you boost it's
interesting because i'm looking at like
google ads for instance why would i
spend money boosting or promoting
content on google or facebook well
because then we get more audience and
then later on we get more revenue from
ads when we serve content back to people
and that's similar for what what the
minds token does
ethereum provides the ability for these
things to function for for real
exchanges of value which means out of
all the the the social networks where
you could be producing something and
making and earning it's like basically
youtube
and
minds
there's because look there's a bunch of
platforms where it's like oh you can
earn tokens and they're worth something
but i always ask people like why do the
tokens have value and there's nothing
really backing it that worries me it
makes me feel like it's not worth the
investment but if mines keeps growing
and getting more users then there's a
more likely advertisers will say hey we
got a network here of millions of people
and as the technology expands it's worth
holding these tokens but beyond this i
don't want to just you know shout out
minds mind you there is i read this
really great article they talked about
how erc20 tokens can be used for
self-driving cars that they can be
they can be used to authenticate certain
uh um
they can track this on a ledger which
cars interact with who and use crypto
currencies essentially as a way to map
out
self-driving vehicles in this massive
national or international grid so your
car comes into contact with another car
and there's an exchange and that helps
them decide which way to go left right
up down and then they have a ledger
where they can see every single car and
they use a blockchain to do it
yeah i mean point being real look for
real value in the crypto projects that
you're you're supporting and you know
yeah there are meme projects that are
fun and don't forget yeah and that there
is value in that i mean you the the
amount of energy that's coming into
crypto because of doge
like
that's bringing in retail investors
that is super important so it's not
black or white like if doge is good or
bad but like don't buy doge on robin
hood like you can never pull out your
tokens and that's just like robin hood
it's just for speculation isn't it it's
just for speculation yeah but you can
get doge in certain places and get the
tokens but gemini now now has yeah i
think you can probably pull them off
gentlemen yeah you definitely can okay
good well i want to say what uh
on gemiini you can buy crypto and then
transfer it to your results i'm assuming
it's true for doge as well i would
assume so although how do you set up a
doge wallet you just gotta use like
metamask or the ledger you can get a
cold storage one and store it on ledger
i believe i could be wrong about that
yeah metamask i don't know you're the
scariest thing about cryptocurrencies
if you accidentally send your crypto to
the wrong address disappear i know you
oh i do test transactions
for a larger i like i look back and
forth for like 10 minutes with my i'm
just like dude sweating i count and i
say j j yeah n capital x capital x one
one
and i'm like there's a lot of money to a
strand i look at the first four letters
from the alpha numeric and the last four
and if they're the same that i but
pretty easy that it copied and pasted
what if what if the i
is actually a one a lowercase l yeah
you're making me nervous tim what if
you're like that's got to be a is that
an l or an i it's funny to think that
uppercase if the last three characters
are the same the chances are
almost no i just look at that yeah yeah
i've not i've not actually had any any
problems with this
yeah yeah money's your money it's up to
you to protect it and control it i mean
it's removing banks they are rolling out
this thing called a social um
recovery where basically you know to
prevent people losing millions of
dollars so basically you would be able
to pick
like five people where if you do lose
your device if a certain level of
consensus is met then you can recover
even if you lose your keys so it's sort
of like this so it's like giving your
giving your like next-door neighbor keys
to your house
yeah so but but giving multiple and they
all have to like convene and like agree
yeah so it's like your your closest
friends have wallets or whatever and
they can say we know we we we back up
you know but they can't like you know
have mutiny like basically you would
have to signal i'm not exactly sure sure
all the mechanics but you know i think
that that that's a major ux problem in
crypto that i think will get solved
eventually word yeah how about we oh
yeah regarding the minds token i want to
integrate it into i don't want to pump
mines too much right now but hey you're
here and i'm glad i want to talk about a
little bit uh integrated into the
fetiverse project because like you were
saying the utility one token is a
thousand views on mines but if we
extrapolate that to all these new
networks where you can interchangeably
use the token well so so we were talking
about creating an open source
uh package you can install on your
wordpress site that gives you a
subscription feature so any person could
effectively have their own kind of
patreon without having to pay an
exorbitant fee to you know 10 or
whatever like people don't realize when
you sign up for these subscription
services you're giving like 10 or 15 of
your revenue to this company and you
could seriously just get your own
wordpress site for dirt cheap it's not
that expensive but i understand a lot of
people like how do i set up a
subscription thing okay we'll make this
thing you instantly install and it just
turns your site into a social media page
and then we were talking about
incorporating crypto and there would be
there would be a big benefit with having
it interact with the minds network
simply because there's already users
there which means
once we assuming we get this up and
running and in some meaningful time
maybe i'll take forever maybe it'll be
fast you could be a random person
because i'm going to make a website for
my content how do i get the word out for
my content well there's already a
network that exists so if this content
can integrate and appear on mines
through federated you know through the
fetaverse then you instantly on your own
website are getting promotion in a
network and then in turn people can subs
can subscribe to the members only
section of your site by using mines
tokens or something and then people
could be like i'll send you a token if
you show my ad on your site for a
thousand views that's already built in i
think the peer-to-peer stuff it just
means that your site could have display
ads that could be functioning on the
minds boost network so it's integrated
with a crypto token already but also
just to just shout out the fetiverse a
little bit more and explain to people
like the dimensions of it so
the two main dimensions of it that i can
see are activity pub which mastodon uses
and then there's matrix which is also
federated which is uh we actually just
launched a
matrix
end to end encrypted chat which can
federate with other matrix nodes so if
you go to chat.mines.com or you can
download the minds chat
at mines.com mobile but it's all these
servers that are connecting enabling
communications to not be able to go down
so activity pub allows social networks
to connect so you can uh connect from
one post from one to another mastodon
makes it so that i mean sorry matrix
protocol enables it so i can
message you from on
my server or a server that i'm a part of
on another server and it can't go down
so
you know yeah i see creators it's end to
end right it's end-to-end which means
you don't have any of the information no
that's the thing man we don't want
people's private information i don't
like people having access to people's
private messages why why would a company
ever why would facebook and twitter want
that so weird yeah dude they're having a
cia book i mean yeah it's
yeah it's wild because i wonder
so i i have uh i send myself messages on
facebook when i'm like if there's a
story or something i need i'll just like
send it to myself so that everybody's
there it's easy yeah yeah and i was
looking at it you know a couple weeks
ago and there was like a bunch of yellow
boxes like this post has been removed
for a violation of community stands or
whatever private chat to myself oh my
god facebook goes in my messages to
myself and removed some stories their
facebook's messages to facebook's self
you were just there to be the corpus to
you honestly you want something really
crazy
when i went to venezuela i had to flee
the country because i got accused of
being a spy by the by venezuelan glenn
beck
when i came back
i got a message on facebook from a
friend i had spoken to in like five
years and he was like yo what's going on
the fbi just called me to call me back
right now and i was like what and i was
in i was in new york so i called him no
he doesn't answer i call him again he
doesn't answer i call him again he has
an answer
so then a couple hours later he calls me
back and he's like tim and i'm like yeah
he's like uh sup you called and i was
like yeah what happened fbi called you
and he goes
what
yeah you messaged me on facebook bro
what are you talking about dude i
haven't talked to you like five years
and i was like shut up dude and so i
took a picture of the facebook message
and he was like dude i did not send you
that
so i talked to some uh
infosec experts and they were saying
that they thought they think what
happened was the venezuelan government
or some actors working with the
venezuelan government
injected facebook so that on my end a
message would appear
they wanted me to make a phone call
so that their cell towers could pinpoint
my location in the country wow
but i was in new york
i left a long time ago but they thought
it was still there creepy right
dude it's crazy stuff i bet i actually
still have that message oh if i go
that's behind the scenes content i
better go pull it up yeah i'll do it
i'll do it for the bonus episode i'll
see if i can pull it up no joke it's
probably not still there no i bet it is
you think so yeah like
all my my messages from my friends on
facebook
they're they're there forever i'll look
into it because it's i still don't talk
to this friend all that often they're
there forever except for when they
delete them right right right that's
what i'm saying all right we're gonna
read some super chats if you haven't
already smash the like button subscribe
the notification bell share the the show
with your friends take the url and just
paste it across the board and uh it's
the best way to help out
and again you know what we're gonna do
um
i'm gonna see if i can find this uh this
this message where
this yeah it's i'm gonna see if i can
find it and we'll have it for the bonus
segment coming up around 11 o'clock
tonight so become a member at
timcast.com we just launched stripe for
memberships
stripe is amazing it really really is um
i'll tell you there's a couple things
about stripe which is awesome for one a
lot of people don't like paypal stripe
mechanically as a service i'm really
impressed but more importantly
the the higher ups at stripe are on
twitter and i like i tweeted them and
they respond and so i've had like i'm
having issues like we got you buddy
don't worry about it i'm like that is so
relieving
like because paypal is a big just
gigantic yeah
yeah they're pretty cool they i i'm
pretty sure they're big fans of
quillette which i think is an indicator
that you know that you know they're open
yeah and locals use a stripe
so i i'm like yeah we use stripe for the
cash online yeah the fact that i can
just like
shoot a tweet at somebody and then like
that that's that's huge so anyway that's
available now teamcast.com you can we
can become a member using stripe and
we're going to have uh we're going to
have a great you know uh segment coming
up let's read some super chats uh and
again smash that like button b anderson
says i know it's off topic but please
shout out i started a fundraiser for my
cat who broke her leg on gofundme search
surgery for fish by ballard a
oh man really poor fish
surgery for fish i think we're gonna
have to make sure that uh this this
kitty gets all of the
help kidding
surgery for fish go fund me
there we go let's see we got here we're
going to make sure
help kylo um
oh uh oh
fish the pup is this i thought you said
as a cat
no that's a dog i searched for surgery
for fish but it but dug him up
let me look up a person
surgery for
fish
ballard found it
kitty needs
3149 dollars
i guarantee you by tonight
this will be completed you have my word
i'm not asking anybody else to make any
donations if you would like to there is
a kitty who broke kitty's leg i don't
know if kitty i don't miss gender kitty
so um
we're gonna make sure kitty makes it yes
earlier today uh so we we got tick
medicine for bucko and he's been licking
nonstop his skin off he has a bandana so
we gave him a little neckerchief i put
it on him so that he can't you know lick
it i saw him today we had the uh the
electricians come out
and i
this cat
walks up right behind the rear tire and
then lays down right in front of it
and i'm like
trying to get up walk out move the cat
because if the dude gets in the truck
and the cat's laying there it's going to
be like a split second the car in the
winter they'll crawl up in the engine to
stay warm that's don't let them out in
the winter yeah so we keep an eye on the
kitties anyway um ballard a we will we
will uh make sure that your cat is taken
care of just shout out to buck oh
there's a very cute picture of bucko and
lydia's instagram there is his little
neckerchief he is so handsome with his
little neckerchief i had to take a
picture of him and he came and snuggled
with me yesterday he's just my best pal
haywood says doge is nothing i put 15k
into cardano 88 in may of last year
guess how much i have now
what was it may of last year like
a few seconds six cents i don't know
that's what that's a dollar seventy
dollars today
yeah so uh trips you have a lot of money
all right
ryan brown says how much trouble did you
have get uh have in getting fit for the
blades you have i'm happy to see you
tried it didn't know brandon tatum was a
blader before oh yeah getting the what
do you mean in uh in getting fit for the
blades that i have like getting them to
fit i'll tell you one thing it's really
annoying how aggressive inline they like
just fit terribly it's like just awful
what is that i don't know i'm annoyed by
all of them like these things just suck
to wear you got some though i got a
bunch yeah yeah oh nice what's up what
size are you me uh 10. oh nice all right
i'm gonna try yeah well no i got like 10
pairs we also got some bikes too you
want a bmx we i i we got to get scooters
next i love so i'm just excited to have
all the different disciplines and so one
of the one of the things is the ground
outside is really bad so it destroys the
wheels of of rollerblades
and skateboarding is really hard to
skate on it because it's just like
really old asphalt that's broken up
there's pebbles everywhere yeah it's
kind of brutal because we could repave
it's really a lot of money but we might
need to it should take a long time but
for bikes that's one i think you can do
these thin coats which aren't like a
full page yeah just like seal it yeah
but i'm excited for the bmx stuff
because uh you can ride on really easily
and then we had mike mike feedy jumped
over the tesla last week it was a lot of
fun he's cool dude he's a cool dude he's
inspired me to get on the bike
all right azir says hey tim love the
show i'm currently saving up money to
travel around and cover protest riots
rally etc would you be interested in
footage how can i contact if you would
like to work together
um pitches at timcast.com
but i must warn you we are just trying
as hard as we can to grow and build and
it's like we are bursting at the seams i
wish we could move faster than we could
but we you lose quality control if you
just start hiring willy-nilly so we need
administrative help to start
the process and i'm really worried about
the peter principle which
that um
i think it's a peter principle where
people hire people who are lower skill
than them until eventually you hire a
bunch of just like really awful people
so
the idea is you always want to be hiring
people who you think are better than you
there's a there's these questions that
peter thiel speaking of peter that he
always asks to people that he's hiring
um
which one of them is
you know what is your most contrarian
belief so but those questions i think
are for anyone hiring are worth looking
up because he knows how to hire people
yeah that guy's an animal you want that
god exists what about you guys you want
to hire people that are going to
[Music]
be really really great and be better
than you
and
take over you want people who who want
to take your job from you
for real not in a cutthroat way in an
ambitious like but but making stuff so
this is no longer needed i mean that's
the idea is so that we can remove
ourselves from the company it'll keep
functioning just people who can be
independent and and intuitive like that
that's who i like to hire i mean that's
why i always love working with ian
because
he figures it out he just and people who
can figure it out without having to be
able to told what
without having to be told what to do
yep yep all right spencer henry says the
atf murdered 86 people in waco that is
all that's right and uh you want
something crazy my dad's side of the
family from waco
oh yeah
samuel bonan says putting together my
game dev portfolio to submit but wanted
to gear something towards tim cast would
you rather a demo for a ghost haunting
game for the new podcast or a news
tycoon kind of game uh how are you at
first person shooters because we have
probably one of the most controversial
ideas for a game
that i don't i don't think i've ever
publicly talked about but privately
everyone's been like but it's like i
like that one yeah we just don't but uh
we need someone who can do a very simple
fps
and uh it's gonna be controversial but i
imagine the nra is gonna be like we
would like to promote this and have this
be available no actually they probably
like get away from us you're
controversial did you ever see the game
super hot yeah yeah that game's awesome
that makes me think of a game like super
hot that came about how you slow time
you played vr version of it no vr super
hot i will so it's like you're standing
there and there are these like wire
frame dudes and they'll shoot at you and
then you literally dodge and the bullet
goes like boom past your head but time
only moves when you move yeah it's
really so it's like you'll see like a
shotgun blast and you'll be like
trying to like dodge it and you can also
i think you can throw stuff at the
bullets
and like swat them and stuff
so it's like you can deflect it with
your guns it's coming at you when you go
you're like if you move too fast they
move faster the faster you move so you
can like swat it there's also a really
fun game um for oculus it's the uh it's
what's called like a robot vr game where
you're fighting robots and you can like
pick them up and throw them i love that
game dude vr is awesome down in the
skate park where we have the basketball
hoop we also have a vr set with much of
those games so you're like
the challenge is if you run to the left
too much you'll go up the vertical and
so you don't want to do that have you
considered getting one of the
uh
strap straps yeah so like you're so so
you can only go a certain range like not
too far at all well you can
you can draw it so that if you move too
far the whole thing turns red but i
would like what i'd love to get is one
of those stands where you're strapped in
and then you can actually run in place
jump and dock and you have like strap
you have a haptic feedback vest or if
you get hit you can feel it and like the
gloves do you think it'll get to a point
where you're
wearing vr like to work during the day
uh what do you mean like just you know
as opposed to looking at your monitor
just like being in vr
i think so yeah especially now because
uh because of kovit people are working
remotely
so one of the problems with
remote working is that we're sitting
here looking at these little screens and
it's really hard to build a culture
and what you need to understand about
building culture in the workplace and
why i'm not like i don't want to hire
anybody around remote i want people who
want to work here they got they got to
be out here because they got to be in
the space for one thing you'll be in the
vlog the other thing is
we need to just be sitting next to each
other so that if someone's like
i just got a crazy idea what if we
bought a you know a hot air balloon
if you're sitting in your apartment and
you're on a zoom meeting and the meeting
ends and then you go oh hot air balloon
anyway and you go back to eating your
cheetos it go the idea goes nowhere but
if you're hanging out in the house and
people are bouncing around ideas they're
playing video games you're sharing all
of these ideas and creating an
opportunity to just write things down
and plan for stuff the more the merrier
you know dude to a certain point if we
could throw in contacts and then be
doing this but all of a sudden we're on
a stage a virtual stage and we can see
everyone on super chat in the audience
and they're throwing stuff at us yeah
definitely they're throwing tomatoes but
the problem is if you're going to take a
video of us
well how would we see them they'd have
to have video cameras imagine that
so imagine what what i want to get is
this imagine if
you have a table at home and you put on
your vr headset and then you can see
your co-workers sitting in front of you
yeah and then you interact as if there
are some shared spaces that are getting
set up like that now it's just about
contacts instead of vr helmets so you
can see the face yeah you just need both
like i could see going in but then you
want to be out dude have you ever spent
long periods of time in vr
long periods like i've seen videos of
people that have been in for days and
days and days just as you can see the
chimps when they put them in vr a little
bit i want to watch it again yeah oh
let's uh let's we've got to talk about
the mind the chimp mine pong with neural
ink before we go right on right on all
right let's read too much over chance
after she'll go deep all right we got
spanish game says tim here's to making
culture check out my board game
cindershire on kickstarter it's a
four-player procedural dungeon exploring
game please check it out will do it must
be a hero quest kyle miller says tim
have you heard anything about a possible
gas shortage this summer
um
nothing real
nothing in the news i have seen that gas
up 22 and people are really scared that
there's going to be a gas shortage but
not enough to where i'd ever say
anything
like it i don't know i will say i bought
an electric car that's right we made a
video called jumping the tesla why how
about a tesla why because i'm like i
don't want to be relying on gasoline
especially when you've got like greta
tunebroken aoc being like banned
gasoline i'm like these people have
political power and you know i don't
know where we're going to be in 10 years
so
plus i got to be honest i like the idea
of electric you're not you're not really
going to go on a road trip with an
electric car you can because the tesla
superchargers you can like there's a
network yeah but yeah and they're
everywhere they're seriously the charges
are everywhere like no joke there's more
chargers than gas stations so you you'd
be surprised maybe it's not true but you
look at the map and it's like just red
dots everywhere the issue is it does
take like 20 minutes to charge up to 80
and so at a gas station you pull up
there for a few minutes you felt the
tank you're good to go
you plug it in you go inside you sit
down you kick your feet you look at your
watch check your phone it's not that bad
20 is okay it's not bad yeah it's it's
worth it i think too because it's like
ridiculously cheap it's like gotta fill
up the tank oh that was 30 cents wow
yeah it's pretty great
but i don't want to be relying on
gasoline man
all right trash panda says ian you're on
fire today i agree there's a very there
are very strange things going on behind
the scenes what are your thoughts
uh
the world economic forum
has a page called the great reset
i think it's behind the scenes which is
the most terrifying thing i can't see it
the proprietary stuff drives me nuts the
behind the scenes stuff that i was
talking about is like has anyone
actually gone to a farm and asked them
is there anything going on
you're like what are you we
we turn on cnn we turn on fox news and
then we argue about the culture war it's
like we went to go buy some like farm
fresh meats and then heard from the
farmers about what they're dealing with
from the federal government i'm like wow
why isn't it like is there news about
that
nobody cares yeah there may be a million
sources of news but there really isn't
that much news like today we were like
what happened today yeah nothing no
there's a lot of news it's just that
we're hyper focused on politics and
culture but what's the news like cardi
b's birthday
it's like news about you actually if you
actually spent 10 minutes to find an
amazing beautiful story that happened
today you could do it yeah you know it's
but is there ever news that's about not
about people yes i found an article i'll
tell you about it afterwards oh cool all
right ken duncan says
you had better call crowder and tell him
you're finally getting it i'm also
wondering what your fa what your
favorite gun you own
i have a hell of a time myself i think
for me
it's whichever i shot last i'm going to
say it's definitely the lever action 357
magnum
man
that is just so much fun is crowder
offended that you took so long to get
his gun i talked to him about it and i
was like out he you know he asked me
what was up and i was like bro i can't
drive 70 miles so i get this like
because i work i work in the morning and
then i've got like two hours after my
first shift where i do my shows and then
irl and i'm like it's not enough time to
get there and back plus i was on a delay
list of time for it for knicks so i've
gone up there filled the form driven
back waited five days gone back no it's
picked it up yeah yeah that's what
you're doing my dad was trying to get a
uh
permit in connecticut and it was just
like it took years wow of going back and
forth sheriff like it's insane but let
me let me just say uh we there's there's
a range a local range and we were
running drills with uh with our good
friend from phoenix ammunition and i was
like i don't know i'm not like you know
super good these guys were really good i
mean the dude from phoenix would like
never miss and everyone there was like
looking at the guy like wow this guy is
really good but uh i just i had a 410 uh
uh a 410 level action and it's just so
fun running and just cranking and
cranking it and we're using 410 slugs so
uh whole lot of fun but the 357 magnum
lever action i just love lever action
guns they're just so much fun that's my
childhood toy gun yeah right like it's
like it's like you know fronts easy but
uh
it's it's yeah so i've uh i've got i've
got a ridiculous amount of guns at this
point
and
you know uh i think i think it's a
mil-spec uh 308 ar-15 yeah it's fun but
it's like you know whatever the m1a
that one's a whole lot of fun yeah i'm
one it's a lot of fun yeah good good
good good fun good fun
all right let's see mr brownstone says
malice shouted you out with dave smith
on you're welcome today and was so
elated with your abolish the police
message being heard by your large
audience i believe he's
he's uh tinkled his sheath
skivvies with a bit of joy
yeah i saw someone tweeting about it but
but my my response is partially rooted
in michael's argument he made a good
point in the show when he said
that he in new york should have the
right to defend himself but the cops
won't allow him to bear arms in the
constitution constitution says he could
and i absolutely agree with his
assessment
however
i don't believe that at the core of our
ideological you know our world views
they're identical my position is i still
actually think we need police the
problem right now is the police are
effectively a sorting algorithm
to put moderates and conservatives in
prison and let the far left go so the
cops are going to be neutral arbiters of
the law and the d.a makes sure that the
far left is cut loose and the
conservatives and the moderates are
locked up so you look at what the fbi
did today with raiding this woman's home
which is the wrong woman but they can't
find
some antifa guy who burned a building
they nope they can't do it so what will
happen is these cops are like i'm being
good
i'm going to arrest both of you and then
the proud boys are the ones who end up
in prison
so look
i think at this point you've got people
based on tribe that are willing to
support a system which is funneling them
into defeat
and if conservatives are about personal
responsibility they don't live in large
you know urban democrat districts
then we should get back to owning guns
and just tell people take care of
yourself
life is not you know candy canes and
rainbows and you should you should you
know respect second amendment keep and
bear arms
all right tina collette says on the
trump nightmare someone is selling a
trump shower curtain i want to buy one
and sneak it into my tds ridden sister's
bath next time i visit at 58 years old i
am still of the very bratty little
sister that would be amazing just to
film her reaction of now
i like that shower curtain 50 60 year
olds are now like
understanding culture like it used to
like you know our grandparents didn't
really get it but now it's like older
people can have fun i'm 40 too but i
feel like a kid i feel like i'm 16. i
look like video games and i want to play
all the time you're an old man for some
reason i don't know what you did but
your camera just changed colors yeah
you're orange now i'm sorry hot yes
call me back
i don't know he left and came back and i
don't know it's weird all right drop
forge survival says as one of the larger
prepper channels on youtube prep
prepping saved my family and from what
i've been told by several others with
the uh with the videos we've created
food water supplies and financial and
finances because you never know be well
tim and team hey you appreciate it
absolutely
joe macinic says tim cast in my tin foil
hat gorilla shirt uh in my tin foil hat
gorilla shirt with my wife in her
diamond hand shirt have you guys heard
of stellar lumens i want to hear a
non-expert opinion of their token by the
way this super chat will be worthless
tomorrow ugh i hope not before
tomorrow yeah right oh worth less not
worthless worth less tomorrow that's
true uh what do you think about lumens
um
i'm pretty sure that mull and weg for
the creative wordpress is involved with
them and they're it it's a little bit
more faster transactions i don't know a
ton about the blockchain though but it's
it's it's a smart contract platform
which is similar to a theory it's sort
of similar to ethereum but like faster
in certain senses but also more
centralized it's not unc20 no
no
all right
tyrell huddle says i am quote some guy
in nebraska that i've heard tim
mentioned a few times before thanks for
the shout out just want to let you know
i am out here and i am everything you
think i am keep doing what you are i
watch every show hey really appreciate
it man you see that family guy joke
where stewie's like i said
stewie says it's like the time i was in
nebraska and then he's like sitting at a
table with a bunch of guys and he's like
so you know the president did this or
something and they're like
so i heard the celebrity did something
and they're like
how's corn doing oh corn corn oh yeah
corn is great they're all like excited
and talking about corn that's nebraska
so i'm sure that's exactly what you guys
are like you really get a new
appreciation for corn when you see it
growing in the fields and the wind is
whipping through it because it looks
like silk
that's cool
i can imagine you running through a
cornfield oh my gosh you're speaking my
love language
eric miller says imagine being in a
meeting and people are discussing how to
run your life but you can't say anything
they can destroy everything you love how
much money how much money would you pay
to speak out well free speech costs you
nothing but your voice
you know so i was taught i was
out to eat with some family and i was
talking to uh
it was one of some of my cousins and
their kids
and we were talking they were mentioning
how their kids their you know 14 year
old girl doesn't care about news at all
you'll never convince her politics is
important and i was like oh i can't
easily and they're like yeah yeah and
she was like no you can't it's dumb and
i was like think about it this way is
there someone in your school that you
really hate she's like yeah and i was
like okay imagine she makes the rules
about how you get to live and what you
have to wear and she was like what i was
like imagine you go to school and she
tells you what to wear would you want to
be talking about why yes and i'm like
that's politics so when you get older
now these other people are telling you
how you got to live your life and spend
your money and you're like who are you
so it's not so much you don't like news
in politics it's that you care about
what's in your life and affecting your
life
little kid you don't care about the
president people can't stand these
boring people talking about politics on
cnn they deliver it so blandly and like
yawn
what is the root of of the word politics
what is it what does it go back to
what's in holy
palace
the police the people metropolitan
that's from the latin right
yeah yeah so it's supposed to be a voice
the polls
it was it was stripper polls
gather around it and then while watching
the beautiful women do their thing they
would discuss they would they would be
discussing like around the water cooler
the way things should be
poll a ticks that picture the
philosopher is in greece yes nathan
o'connell said ian the band and on the
titanic saw their death and faced it
like gentlemen but they still died
remember
and not everyone did on that boat
yeah
not rose you know
man
hey here we go excess dude if you need a
barn drive up to pa and hire the amish
they're not f uh they're not far and
they're good
oh yeah um so we're trying to so you
guys if you've seen the vlog we have the
the steel pole barn where we have like
the venue in it and we need some
upgrades and i've called a bunch of
people and they just you know ghost us
we've had people come out and they're
like man i can't do what you're looking
for it's i i i don't want anyone to
think it's political it's literally like
either we want to build a building and
they're like we'll get back to you and
then they don't or they say things like
we're a local company we can't build
what you want you know you guys want too
much of us we we can't do that we can't
handle that or the cost has gotten too
high or are there different materials
you could use i mean we just want to use
steel
yeah so right now it's a lot of wood and
wood is
what's the right word volumis takes up a
lot of space if we had stronger
materials we could have way more space
and it'd be a lot cleaner and better we
could build geodesic domes we lose a lot
of vertical space a horizontal space as
you go higher because it curves in but
they're cheap and really stable and we
can dig down also maybe we just get rid
of the barn and put one gigantic dome
over it i'm into it hey i did some
research on on the history of the word
politic
uh polis meant city in ancient greek and
then polytease was citizen
so ultimately that's where yes
josh says have you ever thought about
creating an erc20 token a timcast irl
coin based on a smart contract to allow
your viewers limited rights to support
and vote for content you could create a
staking system and apply for it to be
edit on exchanges
it just seems like a whole lot of issues
with the sec i don't want to deal with i
don't know it's a lot of effort it's a
lot of effort but
yeah if if there's real value there
jay otterson says i staked my eth and
it's just growing as i watched you can
do that right now
do what stake your ethereum
yeah and then it would start growing
yeah really yeah how do i do that on
coinbase really or you can either go to
like a truly decentralized staking is
there any risk to losing or anything you
have to get on there's a wait list on
coinbase no there's no risk but actually
when you stake eth on coinbase so you
earn like six percent a year on top
but you won't be able to pull it out
until eth2 fully launches so interesting
so it's like you're still what is what
is eath too it's still going to be the
same ethereum right still the same
ethereum but it's proof of stake like i
was talking about right so it's not all
these you know electricity
burning mining rigs all over the world
it's um
yeah and it's and they're doing sharding
so that there can be more transaction
throughput and there will be the gas
prices will be lower yep
tyler page says ladies find yourself
someone that loves you like bill ottman
loves bitcoin
i'll take
it
zach wilkerson says m2 money supply went
up 6 trillion in 2020 divide that by 365
and you get 16.4 billion dollars created
per day how much did dogecoin create per
day
14 million
it i don't remember what the number was
but so what you're saying is that
dogecoin is a is a more sound currency
than the us dollar
you're saying doge to them there are
everyone should buy it winklevoss just
just posted something like that he oh
really everybody but he was no he was
just saying that it you know compared to
the dollar it is more sound in certain
ways yep
all right stairs in a space gaming says
check out coin bureau and his analysis
of the tokenomics of doge not financial
advice all right
cnnsc says tim i don't know why but i
can't log into the site on uh only on my
android though love the show you should
get attorney tom on from tiktok so i
guess there was some issue on the site
where
there was like a caching error of some
sort if you can clear your cookies or
whatever it should be better
um we're we're
i'll just keep keep it simple we created
a very simple wordpress site we're like
here we'll put bonus content for people
and then so many people signed up i was
like okay we we we need to upgrade the
site to handle this this level of you
know traffic and then we did that and
then more people signed up and i was
like we have an opportunity to actually
create a network and start doing a bunch
of unique content and this kind of site
we're building can't accommodate that so
we're need to bring in the big guns and
so we got like a really big company now
who is stepping in and and
we're expediting the construction of a
site that should allow us to
make shows everyone be patient
developing websites takes a lot of labor
a lot of love it's all about patience so
it always takes three times longer than
you think and
i think in five years we're gonna have
some kind of netflix
it's gonna we're gonna have a bunch of
our own original content short films
movies documentaries and it is going to
be totally independent i'm so ready to
make movies you know what's funny is
when i've had a lot of people come out
here so a lot of a lot of you know
prominent personalities who are assigned
to networks and they're like so giving
it like investors like to help you nope
you don't have any no no investors how
did you do all this so i just slowly
built it up over time
wow no i can't no no no totally
independent 100
nobody gave us any money zero overhead
21st century business on youtube
incredible that's zero overhead it's
absolutely untrue ian well not zero but
it's negligible overhead no it's not
your overhead was like your rent
yeah when i first started yeah you were
making
a lot of tens of thousands of dollars a
month with no like no oversight
right and then when you start getting to
to the point where you're
running a business and hiring people
overhead becomes exorbitant but you i
think took it
to the br like as far as you could
totally solo and and that i think that
was in your benefit am i the only one no
not the only rogan kind of did it he had
jamie he was paying and he has a crew
that's true but he's been doing a lot of
stuff for a long time and he's worked a
lot of differences he's already very
wealthy when he went into it yeah that's
true though that's true though you know
he started his own thing yeah absolutely
he didn't need people to fund him so i
worked for disney left and then i had
some money able to start things and i
worry about it but no no investor is
nobody phil defranco same i don't know
if he took on investors eventually he
started as just some dude in his dorm
room basically yeah what's up with that
guy i've i've actually i don't know i
haven't seen him a long time no i've
been hearing things really and billy on
the algos he doesn't come up as much as
well i remember on the covington thing
he posted a video that took the side of
the establishment which was the which
was
untrue and there were a couple other
things i guess that happened i don't
know i don't really watch them anymore
no no i'm not trying to be disrespectful
i've just been seeing comments on
twitter
maybe they don't maybe they're not
representative youtube flashed me one of
those about jake paul i think on the
last it is it is really crazy to like
for me to look at these other youtubers
who have been around for a lot longer
than me and i get five ten times as many
views as they do stuff happens not on
one single video but just like in terms
of the work that we're producing yeah
quality speaks volumes now whereas back
in the day it was whatever they shoveled
into your mouth in like 1975 because abc
ran the airwaves basically now the high
quality stuff gets caught especially
when you encourage people to share it
and they share it that's massive like if
you if you really inspire someone to
share it that means
a lot of people are getting inspired to
share it it's funny that even like
comedy central now and
others you know they're basically
producing in their houses so it's like
they they had the big production studios
all the mainstream outlets but now with
kovid they're all home
and it's just funny to see the
mainstream producing out of their houses
so it's like with like low quality it
was low quality they don't know how to
want a studio they're just the face you
realize like tim actually understands
the tech behind it dude it's so like me
and you neither of us were technicians
when we were starting minds we had like
super low budget we had webcams and
stuff
thank god tim's like a technologist
gotta you know what cameras to get the
black magic car the switcher all the
the lights the leds all we had to get
was this stuff and you know
interesting people too
yeah navaso says the next bitcoin having
is slated for march 2025. interesting
there was a super chat i just saw and
it's gone
so i'm bummed i don't know where it went
that's a bummer
oh well what did it say
um
i didn't get a chance to see it but i
wanted to read it i don't want to say
unless i can find it but i can't find it
because there's too many super chats
because people love us too much which is
really great you guys are amazing
connor o'brien says bill uh thoughts on
the solana blockchain
they also handle more throughput there's
this app called uh audies which is like
a blockchain sort of spotify app that's
using it and i i like ethereum i think i
think ethereum is gonna is gonna make it
in the long run you know migrating to
different blockchains is just it's all
about network effects
and i just i don't know i i think it's a
cool project and there's cool people
working on it
and really smart people and they're
solving some problems but i don't know
i'm not really trying to endorse or not
endorse different
tokens when we were starting the minds
token and conceptualizing it still i i
kept pushing like we should start our
own blockchain i brought it up a few
times right right people were basically
like nah mark didn't really think was a
good idea are you glad think about how
much energy it takes to get peop you
know tens of thousands of people all
over the world running nodes
like that cannot be underestimated think
about how much energy it takes to get
hundreds
ethereum has hundreds of thousands of
developers
and like tens of millions of you like
that it's not to say that you just go
with where all the people are but like
there's a reason that it's generating
those network effects but like i think
that they're i'm not a maximalist i
think that different blockchains will be
suited for different purposes and also
other times you don't want a blockchain
because blockchains
don't solve every
i won't swear it's just everybody's like
blockchain consulting right i remember
talking to one guy and he was like have
you considered like doing a blockchain
website and i was like what happened
your business should do blockchain i was
like do you know what words are
like i think you saw something on a
story somewhere and now you're just
throwing the word blockchain at me
because i don't know what you're talking
about yeah that's the most dangerous
thing in the blockchain just put the
word blockchain yeah it's so it's nasty
all right heather bailey says how about
a four lights a gorilla t-shirt love all
my others i'm an artist and have a great
design in mind also i love you tim but
could you please stop calling me a
feckless loser thanks oh is it because
you're a cop or what or a politician
um the next shirt we're going to be
doing hopefully is going to be the same
as the diamond hands gorilla but it's a
shiba inu head
and it says to the moon and it's holding
the money and a cigar
so it's not going to explicitly say
though
yeah to the moon
and i hope we can have that tomorrow all
right because i'd love to get that shirt
before elon goes on oh yeah and just did
you get the free the code shirt yet
no no no dude i'll print one i'll put
one on my website there you go
nombot says love love all of you tng is
best but sg-1 is amazing also ian is my
avatar all right really then you have
magic too there you go
all right come on where's that where's
that one super chat i really liked
i was scrolling i scrolled too fast then
it was gone darn it i was gonna make fun
of somebody from nebraska but it's gone
oh wow i can't do anything about it
lydia do you love crypto yet after this
uh
so much
i do feel like i've learned a lot i sent
you that eath seed a few months ago and
i still have that little seedling of
ethereum and i kind of want to add to my
little crypto collection now so we'll
see what happens all right well well
here's one nebraskan rain rainforest
says nebraskan here trust me you won't
enjoy running through a cornfield the
corn rash is real oh
i don't know i watched all those movies
where they're like running through the
cornfields and they're being chased by
these pieces
well it depends on what is sprayed on
the corn i would imagine too true that
could be liposuction yuck
oh come on did it just jump on me again
oh here we go brown coat says politics
so we have an explanation of where
politics comes from politics comes from
pali meaning city or people and tix
meaning evil blood-sucking parasite
parasites
perfect
politics
that's right
nailed it all right
sonny james says people don't understand
there is pretty much zero to n uh no no
vetting of these government contract uh
contracted security security agencies
like palanti palantir evolve et cetera
it's a rubbing elbows with connected
game drones missed their targets killing
civilians in afghanistan up to 90
percent yikes
wow
ossary says ian got trumpized you're
bound to get banned from social media no
indeed oh i don't think ian's been
tripping
tomato i like trump yeah bill can't see
it but socratic disciple says politics
poly meaning many and ticks miserable
parasites
tim you mentioned cryptobots yesterday
does anybody there recommend one in
particular my doggo crypto doubled from
44 to 89 love the show the shogren uh i
don't know about any of these programs i
just remember i just know that they
exist so my friend that built one one
time the algorithm that auto trades he
like built a computer program that did
it for him for a while he's like look
i'm getting one percent yep
it just sells when it's high and buys
when it's low and it just automatically
doesn't
all right we'll do one more just to
trigger uh bill here patrick a glass
says cardano will flip ethereum
okay
um there it is so look i mean cardano is
a is a proof-of-stake blockchain that is
similar you know they're rolling out
smart contracts more power to them
uh i i hope that
products get built um what you know in
term for from a developer experience
ethereum is just great to build on
there's so many developers working on it
there's so many tools
and you know i don't know it's yeah
all right uh justin miller says any word
on the ian alligator shirt i think we
can have that one up tomorrow as well
but i thought i think that was going to
be a mug actually
i'm open to all avenues yeah i think
that was it's a really good mug because
it's a it's a it's a square comic image
perfect yeah but we'll see it's great on
a shirt goes great on your eggs when
you're in the morning yeah whatever yeah
get a hat ladies yeah and gentlemen
smash that like button if you have not
done so already go to timcast.com become
a member because now you can sign up
using stripe and it's really fast and
really easy it's amazing click it and
then a box appears and it's like putting
your info and you do and then boom you
remember it's fantastic and we're gonna
have a really great segment coming up
i'm gonna see if i can track down this
message where i think the uh i think the
venezuelan government was trying to hack
facebook to try and you know figure out
my location and then we'll just talk
about whatever i don't know uh but go to
tps.com check it out you can follow our
show on instagram at tim cast irl and on
facebook facebook account
facebook.comcast irl where you can share
our videos so that other people get
exposed to the show and then we can
drive everybody to our website instead
which will you know help just grow an
independent website i suppose and don't
forget to follow us on mines
[Music]
yeah we gotta i think mines is the thing
where the youtube auto posts to minds
but irl's not auto posting right now we
shouldn't just just tim cass and tim
cassidy we should fancy the irl
experience we'll do that
look diversify your presence that's what
it's all about it's not it's i hate
pitching it's it's not about us it's
about creating a network of networks but
mine's auto auto uh uh yeah you can sync
up yeah you can sync your youtube and
it'll auto post everything every every
uh every new video find me
at opman ott man on minds minds.com
mobile get the new minds chat app
antenna encryption rooms file sharing
fetiverse
check it out oh and you can follow me
ian crossland.net check out all my
social medias from there at ian
crossland including mines you'll see it
at the top in the middle with the light
bulb which is a great uh great insignia
by the way thank you very cool and you
can follow me on twitter at sour patch
lids as i try to figure out what's going
on with the cryptocurrency
we will see you all over at timcast.com
and the exclusive bonus segment thanks
for hanging out we'll see you then bye
guys
you